I you know this is why you know she always makes fun of me for
saying I care about her not disrespecting me publicly but like
I really closely safeguard her reputation. I have not told anyone
this. There's not a single guy friend I've ever told this to.
You guys are the first ears first fresh set of nonlicicensed
counselor ears on this matter. Okay. So anyways my way up the
corporate ladder and so I didn't really have time to really think
about all that. I was just trying to carve a better life out
for us. Okay. Zero.
Zero. I wouldn't even call that abusive. I just think that's
neglectful. But
I believe that just closed itself. God damn it. Get the Nick
Fod. 5 hours. Oh, he has somebody over. Hold on. What is this?
You know what, guys? I will put the camera down and I will mute
it, but I will Oh, I totally forgot. I could have hopped on the
Discord during this. We could have seen what was going on. Sorry.
I was saying I will. Basically, this is apparently um he had
somebody over so he like turned his off uh for hours and hours
and hours he just left his stream running I guess and then about
5 hours 47 minutes he comes back. We're going to do another giveaway
tomorrow. Someone remind me. Comes back. Okay, someone remind
me. I should have some YouTube videos playing. That was very
inconsiderate. I agree. You'll probably get ammo to team viewer
you in whenever you want. I don't think so.
I don't think so. Naughty Fox saying me. Okay. Um, so we got
a 550 time stamp here and then I don't think there's much else.
Oh, 550 is around when he comes back. And now he'll start yapping.
He's going to start yapping about everything. All right. How's
everyone doing? I will absolutely make some content tomorrow.
Yes. Yes, I will. Tomorrow's going to be a busy day for me. I
have to corral the troops and draw the line in the sand and figure
out where we go from here because going forward we're going to
need to basically we're going to need to basically staff up ourselves.
And so that means I'm going to be interviewing people and uh
I will probably offer the existing staff uh an offer to come
work for me instead, right? Because it's time to like look right
now. You have to remember something guys. Oh, he's breaking off.
He's starting his own startup. He's spinning up from Amaranth
startup. He's starting his own. Yo, a lot of y'all, especially
if the haters are here, probably not, which is good. A lot of
y'all think, "Oh my god, he's such a bad guy." It's like, dude,
if I didn't keep up with the payments for the contractors, okay,
they would have already stopped working two weeks ago, right?
She never takes a look at the She never looks at the invoices.
They just stack up. If we're fighting for two days, I come back,
there's like seven of them. If you don't pay them, they don't
come back the next week, you know? Was that your job? It was
your job to pay them. But like it'll be uh by the way, before
this, apparently Amran said she didn't think any of her employees
would jump ship to Nick. And she also said that wait, I think
she just said she doesn't believe any of her employees would
jump. Interesting because once she once she decides to actually
do the stuff she's supposed to do, okay, she'll realize how much
there is to do. Like there's a reason running everything, making
sure the staff is doing their daily post. Another person is making
Tik Toks. It's a whole fullcourt press and I'm already used to
doing it. You said it once, you forget it, right? She's never
said it once and she's going to have to learn to set it once.
That's the gist of it, right, bro? That's That's crazy. Hold
on. He basically said he did he did a one time setup and then
he's been collecting checks after that and she's like but she's
never even set it up once. That's nuts. This script is insane.
Do you want to hear the story? It's so I have to redact some
of it because it's uh sensitive information. But like here's
what happened. Okay. Um okay. I went in because I saw her sleeping
on stream and historically she tells me she doesn't like sleeping
on stream, right? Except in the heyday of the the sleep stream
and and ASMR and all that meta, except for that point in time,
she's hated the idea of sleeping on stream. She's always said
it's made her nervous, blah blah blah. So, she fell asleep on
stream, so I woke her up and I said, you know, well, I first
of all, I turned stream away and then I tell her, "Hey, did you
mean to fall asleep on stream?" And she said, "No, I didn't."
I said, "Okay." Uh, oh god, this is going to happen a lot. Um,
do you want to go to bed? She goes, "Yes." I go like, "Upstairs
or down here?" And then she didn't really answer. And then I
go, "Okay, well, I I'll just leave the the chat then." Um, you
know, basically I turned it away from her, right? And she says,
"Um, oh, mute it." Actually, I muted. We talk a little bit, right?
And then I have something important to tell her, which is regarding
the security shift, right? Something they told me. And so I start
telling her, "Hey, look, um, I'm going to need you to listen
real fast cuz this is about security." And then she hops up to
her feet and says, "What? You're threatening me again?" It's
like, "No, I have a message from them." And then she just goes
like, "Oh my god." Grab her phone, you know, and then Is that
That's Yeah. Oh my god. Runs over, turns it on, and acts like
I'm chasing her. Are we good? Are we all right? Or Runs over,
turns it on, and acts like I'm chasing. What just happened? What?
What? What is he looking at? His phone or Hello. Hello, Nick.
Nick. Hello, Nick. Nick. Hello, Nick. Nick. Hello. Hello. Hello,
Nick. Hello. I mean, look, guys. I don't even really Bro, I'm
sorry. That's weird. A King Gidra. That's what I thought. King
Gedra. That is what I thought just happened right there. That
was crazy. Nose red as have to take the staff, but I'm not going
to. I mean, look, guys. I don't even really have to take the
staff, but I'm not going to take the staff. That's not the way
this works, right? I hired them all. Right. Literally, I hired
them. No way.
No way. No way. Like, which single st This dealer was the one
that came to the house. What the
Interview, hire, pay. I make sure payroll is made every week.
I do all of that. Do you guys understand? Like, so when you say
that I'm going to steal them, no, no, no. Here's what's actually
going to happen. I'm going to go to them and I'm going to offer
them another job role. Okay. If they accept it, great. If they
don't, they keep working for her. It's win-win. Okay. But then
after if I don't have enough staff after, you know, making speed
them up a little bit, okay? I have a few more resumes lined up
and I'll be hiring just brand new people essentially. Like you
have to understand, guys, like I don't have to set everything
up. If I stop uh making payroll, they don't show up anymore,
right? Is she going to do it? Like she's not reliant enough,
you know? Like like like like you can't like so the way it works
for us is you know every week you get a statement. It shows you
the amount of money that's going to go outbound to pay for all
the staff. Staff for what? Staff for him to live his life. Okay.
He doesn't even know how to operate Discord. Is he still in Hold
on. Is he still in Discord right now? That would be really funny.
He's like still in this DM. Hold on. Let me check. Let me check.
He's not. The call lasted two days. I don't even know how that
happens. Salaries. You have to approve it, sign off on it, etc.
Right. The reimbursements included, etc. I have to check that
every week, you know, like the bookkeeping company, the automatic
uh deposit into the employees accounts, every piece of that was
negotiated and set up by me. It's all automatic because of me.
There's no reason I have to keep it that way. You know what I'm
saying? Like this could go back to the stone age real fast.
Y'all laugh about me being tech illiterate. She's life illiterate.
I'm just saying person has never adulted in their life. They've
never filed taxes once in their life. Not once. Okay. I honestly
she makes enough money. You should just pay like a $100,000 for
somebody who's like managed a company before. Just give like
a $150,000 salary to somebody who's got like a clear track record.
Offer them that and go you run this now. Like that that's all
she has to do. That's way less than Nick got. She just won so
hard. Like I don't know until the most recent episode, if you
can even count that, if she's ever even applied for like a form
of uh identification such as getting the passport or renewal.
In 2015, I got her her first passport because she was so she
didn't know how to start, she didn't know what to do, she didn't
know to get the visa, where you go. The point is like this is
going to be very interesting. I I'm actually eager to see um
how well someone who's never adulted will do at adulting. Bullface
life. What part? the part that I hired them, the part that I
pay them, the part that all the instructions I give are given
from me to them. I'm not I I would never make someone say you
work for me. That makes sense, right? Even though I'm a principal
at the holding. Remember the day when he was super manic and
he called the cops from the crowbar assault? He went in the bathroom
for like 30 seconds said hopefully you couldn't see me. Nothing
to see there. I figured he was doing lines then too. Oh jeez.
Company and I have that right. I'm not going to do that. I don't
like involuntary employees. What I'm going to offer them is a
different role, right? With different responsibilities. um and
defined benefits, right? And they're going to choose the one
that's best for them. It's a win-win for them. They're either
going to pick something they like more or stick with something
they like more. This is all written out on paper as a story,
right? And that story is called the origin of Nick Wickley. That's
what the story is called. The origin of Nick Wait, I was essentially
her employee. How did you get that from that? Like if you're
going to look at like uh who's an employee of the company, well,
technically me and her both are. So, we're an employee of the
Investigate get those messages popping up. Okay, maybe see how
that works. Hell, hold on. Amaranth is even licensed to the LLC.
And she hires one person there, new me. I would love to see it.
I would love to see it. You know, you should ask her, right,
when she gets her half, can I just give it to her in cash and
she can pick where to invest it? Ask her what she'd say. She
said, "No, no, no, no, no, no, no. I want I want them the money
already invested." And that's how you'll know. It's like, "So
what? You're going to keep it in those stocks forever? When are
you going to sell it? You have no idea." I see a bigger, better,
smarter man. Nick from Wall Street. Nick, stop wearing Richards.
I know they're expensive, but buy something more classy than
Rishard. Listen, Rishard Meal. I know. I used to be of the camp
that thought Reishard Meals were tacky. You think Nick invested
in Nvidia? Uh, maybe. I used to think that. A lot of really lot
of really changer people invested in Invidia. So, I have interacted
with a ton of the top watch brands in the world. I have a pretty
strong relationship with Paddock, Rolex, AP, and Reard Mill.
Of all of those brands, Reard Mill treats me the best. They invited
me and Kate out to so many activities. I got to meet, you know,
the founder. I got to meet the founder son. I got to listen to
them give a private talk about, you know, the ethos of the company
and I've gotten to wear and own a few of the watches and I will
tell you right now, it is my favorite watch company. I know it
people say it looks crass. People say it's not classy. I have
classy watches. I'm going to show you some in a second. Right.
I have classy watches. That's not the problem, dude. Okay. I'm
sorry. I like actually it's super hard to watch Nick just do
solo streams. Okay. Super difficult. I got I'm going to keep
listening for a little bit, but it keeps time, right? It's usually
made out of precious metal. Okay. And so what makes it classy
that it's a design uh from 200 years ago. I love what Rard Mill
has done. It's incredible. The watch company didn't exist in
2020 or or 2020 even or 20. Sorry. The watch company didn't even
exist in the year 2000. I don't think they're founded until 2001.
They're the youngest what I would consider in the upper echelon
of the Swiss watch makers. And the reason is because the guy
didn't come in and try to make watches that were copycats of
the classy watches. He came in with his own philosophy with his
own, you know, res on debt and he made a watch company that mirrored
his taste, his interests, his aesthetics, right? And the idea
was he was the one who pioneered Formula 1 car on the wrist.
That was him. Okay. I like them. They're good. They're they have
staying power. Mark my words. In 100 years, people are going
to look at Rishar Meals the same as they look at APS easily.
I think they already do. Honestly, I think RM is already higher.
But regardless, at least they're push and withdraw all my efforts
doing her stuff. It's dunzo. It's dunzo. Sorry. He was just showing
off his G his his super awesome watch. I was going to say something,
but yeah. No, super awesome watch. He's showing off his awesome
watch. I know his nose is red. I know. Whatever you want. I don't
give a Today is or I guess technically yesterday, but at least
they're pushing boundaries. Wait, wait, wait, wait. What did
he just say? Did I just mishar that? Whatever you want. I don't
give a Today is that's cool. But can I have your blessing to
your wife? Yeah, you can whoever you want. Sorry, that's what
he was. Yeah, you can whoever you want. But it was about his
wife. Yeah, you can whoever you want, dude. Stop. Stop. Stop
giving these optics off, Nick. Please, for the love of God. I
guess technically yesterday, but like I'm still awake, so it's
today. It's the first day that I'm going to really put my energy
behind me and withdraw all my efforts doing her stuff. It's done
so. It's done. So, done. Here's the thing, right? Whether I help
Amaranth or not, after the kit contract, it's done. It's done.
Like, she has no desire to make content. The only desire to make
content is to document the drama between us, which I find very
annoying, you know, but it is what it is, right? I love that.
That content is awesome. I I think he's missing out on something.
That content is cool. Like that's all that's her only desire
to stream right now, right? You want I have time stamps, Maximus.
And it's like it's the funniest off in the world, right? I wake
her up and say, "Hey, do you want to go to bed upstairs?" And
suddenly she's going to All the time stamps right now are like
3 minutes apart hours and make me extra couple of$4 to $8,000.
He just doesn't stop for that to happen. It was not my intention,
right? But like all I was trying to tell her was like, "Yo, the
security has a message for us and we need to start doing this."
And she was like, "Oh my god, he's threatening me." It's like,
"No, I'm just passing along words." But okay. You know, dude,
he is cutting something up or he's typing on his phone. Maybe
he's just looking at his phone, but then his head doesn't dip
all the way down. Maybe she's just tired warning dealing with
you. Maybe it was just the phone. You hear like the Oh, you can't
really hear that through my mic, but you can hear it kind of.
I promise you this. Okay. She think I'm a handful. Yeah. handle
for this household, for this business, for the finances, for
everything is like seven handfuls. Okay?
Like, you ever heard the expression um what is it? Uh what is
he I don't know what he's saying right now. Does he understand
that he's getting paid like 500,000 to a million dollars a month?
Like, right, you're making like 500k a month, like 400k a month.
You are being paid way more than anybody else who does your level
of duties anywhere in the world. Out of the stove and into the
kettle or what the is that expression? Out of the out of the
uh out of the frying pan and into the fire. Sorry. Jesus. Oh,
sure. Out of the frying pan into the fire. That's what it is.
She thinks this is annoying, bro. Welcome to every long-term
interpersonal relationship where the couple works together. We
do it in my opinion pretty well. There's nothing there's literally
nothing harder to do in the whole world than go from not really
spending any time with your spouse to spending all day with your
spouse. Okay, that's just up. My parents had to go through this
um because my stepdad's sick. my stepdad had stopped working
and stuff and like my mom wants to take care of him, but also
they went from like he was gone like 10 hours a day to he's at
home the whole day and they worked through a very long period
of just like I can't be around this person for like 24 hours
a work cuz my mom's retired and I don't think anything in the
career or whatever has changed. You don't realize you don't realize
like how long um you don't realize how much your job like keeps
you happy with somebody. how like having different interests
in different things keeps you happy until you get forced together
and you're like, "Oh, fuck." In the dude, my my ex right before
co wanted to get a place together and I had just like I think
we we spent like, you know, a weekend together and I was kind
of losing my mind and she asked me to get a place together cuz
her lease was going up and I was like, "No, I don't think I'm
ready for that." And that relationship just immediately tanked.
That was over. The second I was like, "No, I don't think so.
I've spent we spent like a lot of the past 48 hours around each
other. We took like a weekend trip. No, I don't I don't think
that would be good. The last like nine years. Things have only
gotten better, but there's a lot of anxiety because her relevancy
is waning. The contract is ending and she's, you know, put the
team under a lot of pressure to find the next thing. But she
has no desire to actually do the next thing. And so, everyone's
just spinning wheels. And all I'm going to do is offer them the
people that I hired and trained, by the way, the opportunity
to work with someone who actually cares. Shakespeare pay. Uh-oh.
Ribbon. What's up? Donated $3. Your ex, what was his name? Actually
wants to joke and who will implement the ideas that they come
up with. Well, you know what, guys? If you think I'm the failure
in the relationship, keep tuning in to her stream if she even
bothers to stream. You'll see this don't get any better when
I'm gone. I wasn't like trying to be a dick. I hope Amar didn't
think I was trying to be when I said this, but yeah, sometimes
Amrath can seem kind of miserable on stream. When she goes out
and does IRL stuff, it's fine. But uh when she's just sitting
at her computer, man, listening to like AI generated, I'm just
like, dude, what are you what are you doing? What is happening?
Like you seem not cool. If you guys really There's a reason she's
stuck with me. If she has been miserable for so many years, I
wouldn't want that. You know, if she has felt miserable for years,
it's because she lied and pretended to be fine because of the
money, right? Because nothing has changed. Wait, what? You know,
if she has felt miserable for years, it's because she lied and
pretended to be fine because of the money, right? I mean, maybe,
but you guys invest so much of your money. Wasn't it wasn't it
more like she was sort of lying to keep the relationship like
Okay. I'm sure it wasn't misery the whole time either, although
she worked a lot. I don't know if it could have been the money.
Like I I feel like if it was the money, although there is also
this thing that I'm not super familiar with, but I've heard from
some people who are successful that when you start like really
making money, it can drive you to like continue to compound money
without like a real drive to spend it at all. Like literally
just I'm going to rack up like hundreds of thousands of dollars
in my checking account. Like I'm not even going to do anything
with the money. I just see the big numbers and they make me feel
good about myself. Possible something like that was going on
too because nothing's changed. Yeah, I know. Um that's what I'm
saying. like beautiful, right? Normally she doesn't like sleep
streaming, but if I tell her, "Hey, I'm going to turn it off
for you." She'll be like, "No, I want to stream right now." It's
like, "All right, I guess you can make me more money. That's
fine." Dude, there's no way kick gives them 4K an hour for sleep
streams, right? I have 96 people watching because I went AFK
for 5 hours. I had like 200 something earlier. And given that
I've been streaming for a week and only have 2,000 followers,
a 10 engagement ratio is bonkers. Hell, even now at 88 viewers,
I got a like I got an astronomically higher ratio of followers
to viewers than anyone on Kiku Live right now. Okay? And you
have to remember, I didn't even make my stream after I shot the
guy. I could have, but
didn't. 88 viewers at and then I just put my stuff at home. You
know, my house will actually be organized and won't smell like
dog I'll only have the three birds. You know, this is already
not good. Okay. Um, if you're ever sitting there, you're leaning
back, you're kicking it back. Uh yeah, I know litigious gamer.
If you're ever kicking back and you're just explaining all the
things you want to do and how you're going to make your life
better and you're not writing any of it down, you're not really
doing anything. Uh that is just you bloiating. Okay, that's just
bloiating. That's all it is. But yeah, travel streams is a phenomenal
idea. Um I'll have to see if Jacob or whoever else is down to
be a travel camera person cuz I don't think he can do it well
or right with just one person. Wait, what do you mean? I have
four birds. Oh Well, okay. I don't know. We'll see how they we'll
see how they get along with each other. the ring down the point
of reconciliation. Listen, one last one last I'm doing one last
clip. Okay, one last little bit here. You know what? Let's lean
into the ego mania since you guys want clippable content. Wow.
Let's lean into the ego mania, guys. I'm doing this for the lols.
This dude is not nearly naked enough. I I did it. I This is unironically
how he sees himself. Yes, this is how he sees himself. He is
a generous god. Okay. He bequeafd with millions of dollars. tens
of billions in fact. And now without even crushing her, he will
go off into the sunset. All he demands is half of the earning,
current earnings and net worth. Okay. Sorry. Future earnings
and net worth. That's all he demands. He is a generous guy. I
wore it way better. Wow. Okay. I wore it way better. So to answer
your question, I am a generous god. Oh gosh. You explain how
Xerxes is the bad guy in 300. Uh he wasn't respecting the sovereignty
of borders. He's just Putin. Next question. I have to like yep
up that part of the persona so hard. I'm a generous god and if
she apologizes, I'd consider it. But you know what? No way. I
will never ask for it again. That's my new policy. I'm never
going to say maybe you should apologize. I'll take an apology.
That's the last time I'm saying it. Dude, he's hoping so hard.
This guy yaps so much. Maybe he's the one who should be.
You either apologize your own valition cuz you actually feel
bad or you don't. Okay, I have nothing to feel bad for. Okay,
I have done everything with bequath meaning to sound like be
quiet thing. I am supposed to have gone above and beyond. You
know, we're rich. You made a mistake. Name a single mistake Nick
has ever made. We have all the things that we like and desire.
Okay. And then to top it off with the cherry on top, I shot at
three bad guys who were armed and holding her hostage. Oh my
god. You name you name another husband. the last husband who
did that. You know what, Nick? I don't know if I know anybody
who saved their wife from three random invaders. I'm trying to
think. Guys, I am a generous gone because she was locked out
of the master. Sure, sure, sure. I'm just trying to listen. I'm
trying to say
I There's a joke, but it's uh not appropriate here. I really
can't tell it. I shouldn't have brought it up. Okay,
you know what? I can't think of anybody. Let's just He is a generous
god. Okay, he's a generous god. save her life even because I
saw them being dropped off in the tray for the automobile keys,
which is not where they belong. This is what happens when you
take stuff and you just throw it into whatever container that
looks like it should be held in. She would have never found those
keys. I didn't even hide them. I've never used those keys. I
just know that they don't belong in the tray with the car keys,
but yet that's where everyone keeps putting them. Listen, my
wife occasionally misplaces household items, and I quietly place
them back where they should have gone before. I am a generous
god. I am a generous god. Dan, there was a time when one of my
wife's dogs had jumped up on the fence and caught its collar.
It was in fact nearly strangling itself on the fence. I fairly
quickly went and relieved the animal of its collar so it could
not suffocate to death. I am a generous god. I am a generous
god. POV, you just did anything any normal human would be would
do in the exact situation you were placed in. Nick POV, I am
a generous god. I am a Yes, I am a generous god. Jeez. Okay.
Well, that was a pretty good apology, I guess. All right. All
right. Why did he just get texted? What? Anyways, guys, it is
time for me to bid you a dude. Go to bed. I'm actually turn off
the stream before I wink it this time. That's right. Y'all missed
the winking stream. He jerked it. He jerked it. He jerked it.
Oh Okay, here we go. We're skipping over to the next Amaran stream.
We've only got a few timestamps. Most of it seems to be unrelated.
Most of it seems to be not much going on. Okay. There's part
of her in the car. Also, I don't know. It's possible that there's
other stuff going on here, but around here, we're going to get
a bit of an argument in the car. Yes. Right. Right here. Emma
returns and reflects on therapy. So, they had just gone to therapy,
apparently. Would have been funnier if he said he was going to
go hit the sack, then hit the bed. Okay. All right. Well, he's
not exactly Oscar Wild, so we'll give him his laurels where he
can get them. I didn't feel progress yet, but they recommended
individual therapy. Like, here's the thing that Nick and Amaranth
both have to understand. If you want to fix this, you are going
to have to go to therapy for years, right? Like, think of when
you started becoming unhappy. And then for how long you've been
carrying like that resentment, that's probably how long you're
going to go to therapy for. Like, it's going to take a long time
to fix whatever's here. So, you have to decide if you really
want to invest and be there for that long or if it's better.
You know, like the blue book on your relationship is like 400
bucks and the repair bill is like $10 million. Okay? Like your
relationship is kind of deteriorated to the point where it's
worth nothing and the insurance company really doesn't. They're
like, "Dude, we're not covering this." And like you shouldn't
either. Actually, this is we we got to write this relationship
off the road. Okay. The funniest was her casually deciding to
meet him at therapy and him heading home first, then turning
around and seething in traffic. Wait, was he driving as well
at the same time? Oh, they're streaming at the same time. Oh
my god. Amaranth is about 15 minutes behind Nick. So, what about
four hours of Nick's stream? They're both going at the same time.
Just be your pay.
Hold on. Reuben donated $3. He's no Oscar Wild, but Amarant probably
wishes he would be more like Ernest Hemingway.
Like hemlock. I got it. I got it. I got it. That was just fine
with me. Okay, hold on. In the document, I've got I've got them
kind of out of sorts a little bit. Okay, hold on. Hold on. So,
he was streaming at the same time. Here's his VOD. Oh, we got
this going really timestamped far in. What? Wait, this is the
amate. What? Oh, it's not Nick's VOD. Wait, where's Hold on.
Nick's stream is here. Okay, Nick's stream is here. Hold on.
Oh, please stop. Please stop. Kick. Kick. Dude, this this site
crashes so much. It'sing crazy.
like this. This tab is I'll close the tab and
maybe it'll load now. Okay, loaded now. All right. All right.
All right. Okay. This is his VOD from that day. Now, hold on.
Nick's stream ammo stream is about 15 minutes behind. Yes. Why
did I click in so weirdly in terms of the time stamps? That's
very strange. Oh, did I look at this wrong? I did. Okay, never
mind. I I looked at this wrong. So, this is where we go. We go
30 33 minutes in. I looked at the document wrong. That's my bad,
guys. Here we go. Here we go. Okay, let's go. In Vegas in a penthouse
hotel room that I did not pay for. It's amazing what being funny
and attractive will do for a dude. And now I have money, too.
So true, Nick. I often think this. I often think this.
He's really just spitting now. We are in the porch. We're in
the porch. No, no, no. He's just He's just spitting now. Let's
go. This is my favorite car to
This Gates acting weird. Such a douchebag. Wrong. That's the
only thing. That's literally the only thing that uh was timestamped
here. It was just that quote. That was it. Which is very funny
to me. Hour 13. Nick getting tailored. Getting suits tailored
while Amaranth is visiting her horse. Okay. Oh man, I actually
am dying to see how Nick interacts with people in a store. I
didn't realize that this is actually what I wanted to see. Nick
going to a store by himself. It's going to be awesome. Interacting
with like the help at a store.
Oh, now I'm excited. Put this at the ground for now. Sorry. Hello.
How's it
Perfect. Hello. I think uh someone contacted that like my made
to measure stuff was uh
Yeah. Yeah.
Wow. Bruh. Bruh. That's a purse. Why you got a purse? That is
an actual purse. Is Amaran with him? Is he holding Amaran's purse
or
brother? I don't even know if he's got the arm strap to call
it a satchel.
Dude, I'm just having this like awesome vision in my head of
like Amaran and Nick. Not quite in the relationship dynamic,
but Amaran and Nick going to like the oh the Louis Vuitton store
or something. Like they're that blonde girl and the old guy who
are going on the sugar baby date and Nick is just like, "Oh,
mommy, I really like this one." And he's like picking out man
purses. I It's in my head. I can see it. Ivy and Terry. Yes.
I don't care about her name, but Terry was a legend. Yes.
I guess there's
point. Why do they have gay club music in the store? It's crazy.
When the on average Oh, this was like the same time that Ammo
was shopping at Goodwill, apparently. Oh, wait, hold on. No,
this is a different one. I love a bargain, but I always forget
that. Is this the same? Yeah, Hannah went to like Goodwill. Sometimes
vintage is fun. She loves a bargain. That tab just crashed. I
hate I hate kick right now. Kick is really struggling for me.
It's very frustrating. Over any length of time exceed. That's
when I think it'll count. Okay. 2 hours 2 minutes exposing the
truth about. Yes. 2 hours 2 minutes is when we get uh Amaranth
and Nick on bone. That is loud as Hold on. That is loud as What
the hell?
What the hell do
I press charges when I see that? So if you have them, uh, DM
me on Twitter. What? That's way What is that right? I will press
charge. I have to go back and hear what he was talking about.
Slipped. No. No. That's a fire truck. I don't know why they have
a fire truck. Kind of doesn't make any sense, but all right.
She's screaming with Sketch now. Oh. Oh, really? Maybe she's
asking Sketch for tips on uh on technique. Sketch obviously has
like a thing or two to teach her.
So, thanks for the wind nicks, guys. Thanks for the wind nicks.
Remember mods, let some naysayers say their peace. My momento
dude. Okay, so I don't at the time she just looks at the camera
and doesn't say or do anything. It's creepy. Nick, you just going
to allow Joe Peach to post your nudes in his public telegram?
Revenge is a serious crime. Is that what he was talking about
then about pressing charges here? I will press charges when I
see that. So if you have them, DM me on Twitter.
Your call has an automated. If she actually ghosts me on this
therapy that she wanted to do, that would be wild. I'm asking
her, do we meet there or do we take separate I'm saying, do we
meet there or do we take separate cars because that makes a big
difference, right? If I go home and then go there and she goes
straight there. Jesus Christ. Hey, uh I I I I never got the plan
from you. Are we uh are we perfect? Okay, that's what I wanted
to know cuz I wanted to go back and then go there if you're already
going there. Okay, so he's going to meet his wife at therapy.
Okay. Are you streaming it? Okay, good. All right, fine. Uh I'll
see you there then. See you. Bye. Okay, she's going straight
there. I think he's there.
Wait, what?
Okay, weird. Um, sure. Whatever. That was a weird I guess like
the hangup didn't happen for like a second or something like
that. O, boys, I'm in trouble. There's like a traffic jam on
my way to there. I'm going be like 5 minute late. From what I'm
seeing in the time stamps, he seems to be in more trouble than
he's not. Let's check it out. Plus, like it's like on the third
floor, so I'm probably like 10 minutes late. Well, I wish she
um I wish she told me earlier when I first uh texted her. That
would have changed the direction I pointed the car in because
right now I'm on the way home. Did he just ask if they were streaming
therapy? I don't believe so. I think what he was asking here
was actually something more along the lines of like are you streaming
driving to therapy? I think they get concerned about getting
like the stuff they go to doxed. I think that's it instead of
on the I do not think there's any way they were talking about
streaming therapy actually. But maybe I got to it is that turn
at some point to go the other direction. But it's fine. We'll
deal with it. Why will we deal with it? Cuz we're men. I've never
seen a more GPS. Oh sh We're in rush hour, aren't we? What? Boys,
it is what it is. So he's going the wrong direction in rush hour
traffic. Jesus Christ, dude. Is this man? And we still got to
get turned around. Oh boy. That's true. I can make up some time.
It depends on how gridlock it is, right? Cuz if it's actually
like this much because of gridlock, you can't you can't even
weave out of gridlock like this.
Okay. So that that call was made like 2 seconds after he pulled
out of the mall parking lot, right? He's pointed towards home.
Man, holy dude, look. I'm still stuck at this light. Waiting
on a quote here. You don't want to know tiny man? What I got
to do to get it fully erect and show you? Some people are growers,
man. Oh, that's as bad as Aerodite doing the it's bulking season
response. Why would you respond to this, dude? Don't respond
to this. Do not respond to this, man. All I will say is I've
never had a complaint until Ammo. You've been monogous with your
wife for 10 years. That's not really All right. Oh, sorry. The
escorts. Not no escort has ever told me I'm small. No woman I
was ever paying hundreds of thousands of dollars to sleep with
has ever told me my dick is small. So, put that in your pipe
and smoke it. Okay. Like, she's just doing it because she thinks
it gets under my skin, which it does not because Oh my god. I'm
sorry. That does not Oh, that doesn't compute. I'm sorry. Can
we get a fat aerodite emote? No, we can't get a fat audite emote.
I'm not doing that. That is not That is too far. I will make
jokes sometimes, like passingly, but no, I'm not going to make
fun of aite for bulking. That's not funny. It's not something
I've ever been self-conscious about. You want to know something?
Okay. It's It's actually funny, but I just don't want to do it.
Okay. Something I'm actually self-conscious about is this. Am
I talking too loud? By the way, I'm trying to project my voice,
but I don't know if I'm being just too loud.
The only response when somebody uh when there's just one response
when somebody comments on your dick size, there's only one response.
I don't care.
Feels good to me. I don't care. Too big. too small. I don't care.
Just right. I don't care. Makes no difference to my experience.
Why are you telling me this? I don't care. I don't care. Okay,
good. C certainly do not litigate your size with your chat. No,
no, dude. Like, uh, so let's be honest here, okay? Like, I have
never had a size complaint ever except for Kate. And she's trying
to do it to get under my skin, which is okay. Um, it doesn't
bother me because like I know this sounds like I'm bragging,
but I'm not. It's just she has very tight
orififices.
Okay. Like vagina is fine. Um her mouth is like I guess smaller
than usual. And so like that's why I I made the comment that
she got extremely tight orififices.
Sometimes
can be she's not very,
you know, you know what I'm saying?
Orifice is tight. know, uh, conscious of that while she's doing
it. But like tiny mouth, massive hands. She complains that it's
hard for her because she has to hold her mouth wider than she
normally would at like any kind of resting position. Therefore,
you know, it's because her mouth is too small. It's weird that
someone whose mouth is too small is complaining that someone's
is too small because if my was any smaller, it would be better
according to her. Quad a rat demonstratum. My dick is the perfect
size. Okay, Q E D beat the tiny allegations. Okay, it's over.
It's over. I won. Chalk up another W for Nick. But like I said,
she's not trying to be actually critical. She's just trying to
get under my skin. You get what I'm saying? Like it might work
if I've been dating a girl for as long as I've been with Kate
and I've never had that problem. Then I might be like, "Oh, she
actually does think I'm small." Maybe, right? Even then I wouldn't
care. But like, you know, cuz it's like, okay, well then maybe
not the right person for me. But like in her case, it makes no
goddamn sense. Dude, you guys, I'm not I ain't even kidding here.
That is a great topic for therapy. A great both personal and
marital therapy. Yes, Nick. That is a great topic for your personal
therapy and marital therapy. Yes. I'm going to actually just
ask that at some point. So why do you do if my is a girl? You
say you claim your position is that it is
made you've made the observational claim. Okay. The descriptive
claim that my is small. I wish for you to defend that. Okay.
I believe it is not founded in any logical truth whatsoever.
This is so I'm not taking that exit. Something's up there.
Listen. Listen.
Okay, Miss Lady, you can be the you can be the judge. Okay. Is
this a tiny? Is this a tiny I didn't think so. Thank you. I know
it is. Now tell my wife that. No, guys. Guys, um if you care
about it, uh DM me on Twitter or Instagram therapy questions
that would be good for me to ask or or topics to bring up. I
mean, you could say it in chat, too, I guess, but like I don't
have any way of writing it down. I just have to remember it.
I'm driving the Porsche. Most days I drive the Porsche. I usually
drive the Porsche or the Rolls-Royce. Um, if I'm driving any
other car, then like I'm probably just driving the car for funsies.
I mean, I still go places. Okay, I think I'm got to skip time
stamps now. Hold on. With the other cars, I just don't usually
like if I'm driving the other cars, it's pure bliss. Listen,
guys. Okay, anybody you sign up for the Patreon, anybody oil
tier or higher can now suggest questions for me to ask at therapy.
Okay, I will listen. You want to go to
patreon.com/jok new oiler perk. You can submit questions for
me to ask my Okay, brand new patreon.com/jok. You want to go
sign up? $2, $5, $25 tier. Brand new perk just announced. You
can suggest to me questions for my just like Nick just did. Okay,
I'm ready to copy the tech. Asian chicks love BWC. Sorry, tiny
man Nick. Oh my god, dude. I just watched the goddamn thing tick
up seven
What in the ever loving man? Okay. 220.
I don't know if that's what allocated but I stay late even when
I'm not right. And so uh Oh god. No. No. He's going to talk about
how he saved her again.
Sorry. From her parents. I started building. You're supposed
to go there and uh observe it physically and you know obviously
walk it down, make changes, etc. Right. And so for a period of
time I had to commute like two hours to work one way. But because
I would dedicated my wife, my new wife, my only wife, and because
I was young and dumb, and because she asked for it, I basically
did a round trip, call it 3 to four hours a day. I loved that
time. I was in a car. I was listening to podcasts. I learned
so much, but it's it was taxing. I'd have to leave at like 7
in the morning to get there at 9:00. And even if I left work
at 5, I wouldn't get home until 7 at the earliest. And then usually
I'd go to the gym. So I wouldn't be home until like 8:30, okay?
Like 5 days a week, obviously. And every time I'd come home,
Kate would be in the exact same spot
on the upstairs couch watching TV every time. And after
sorry, sorry. Never once was Amaran at the door waiting for him
to come home. Okay? Not once. She would just be sitting there
watching TV. About 6 months of us living together, I asked her.
And And here's the thing, right? I'd come home and I'd say, "I'm
home."
There's no way. There's no way. I've just watched Dude, this
guy's got nothing new. We might have We might have just totally
Listen, where's Where's the infiltration clip? Okay. Any of you
guys watch Street Fighter? cuz uh I think we can say it. Okay,
downro complete. Downro complete. Okay, we figured this guy out
completely. I just I just predicted exactly the next lie. No
answer. I got to go upstairs and find her, which is fine. But
then wait, hold on. Free infiltration. Didn't infiltration get
in trouble? Did Didn't he do something bad? Actually, did I just
He was super cool when I watched fighting games, but I think
he actually did something bad, didn't he? You know, one day I
was like, "Hey Kate, it would be really great if like just occasionally,
you know, you like cleaned like just after yourself really or
if you like, you know, I don't know, greeted me when I came home."
Yes. You know, maybe even at the door if possible. Nailed it.
Another year and a half goes by. You ready, guys? I ask her this
every couple of months. She does it. Guess the number of times
she actually uh does any of that. Guess. I'll wait for the numbers.
I'll give you a hint. It's the easiest number in the world to
remember. It's zero. Zero.
457 days. I count it,
dude. Oh my god. The resentment is insane.
Zero. And I stayed married and I stayed supremely loyal to this
woman. I was popular at the time.
really popular. Ironically, like my Twitter DMs currently are
like my text messages back then. But I was driven to grind my
way up the corporate ladder. And so I didn't really have time
to really think about all that. I was just trying to carve a
better life out for us. He was trained. But I was driven to grind
my way up the corporate ladder. And so I didn't really have time
to really think about all that. I was just trying to carve a
better life out for us. Okay. Zero.
Zero. I wouldn't even call that abusive. I just think that's
neglectful, but whatever, right? Zippo. Anyways, and then she,
you know, started streaming and then running the company, uh,
her own company that I funded and did the marketing for. Just
So, I'm looking for a little quick test clip in the middle of
this. The one that I was talking about earlier. Give me a second.
I I think I found it real quick. Somebody sent it to me. Okay.
Or at least something close to it.
Um, I I'm about to find it. Hold on. I did all of her social
media for the entire time that she's been a social media personality.
Her account, you ready? Her account on Instagram had 1,800 1,800
followers when I started. Nick,
let's million precoid. Her Twitter I grew to the current number
because she had a Twitter with 25 followers. I grew all 3.6 3.7
million of
Right.
Oh, over dummy. Thank for the two gifted. Let's go. We are two
subs. We are two subs plus 22. We are five subs away from another
hour on the stream. Ditto for all of the other ones. YouTube,
especially in the early days, you know, all of them. Okay. And
even on her stream, you have no idea, guys. You have no idea.
And and here's the thing, right? The reason why I tolerated so
much from Kate is because I knew that she and this is where she
gets super mad at me back then. We agreed that she did not have
good parenting. Oh, I told you. I told you. I told you he saved
her from the parents. That's what he did. That's how he held
this over her. That's the That was the first original. I saved
you. Now she's like indignant. I could even suggest that. It's
like, dude, if it's not, look, I'm being charitable back then
when I said bad parenting, it's either bad person or bad parenting,
man. Right? If you had good parenting and you turned out that
way, I don't know. So, obviously, back then, she would readily
agree. I'm so positive that if we get this guy streaming like
this with this level of like uh what would you call it? Like
emotional Oh, I'm thinking of the word. When he when he's like
emotional like this streaming with the chat on, he is going to
rear end somebody 100%. Right. He's going to get angry. He's
going to put his foot on the gas. He's 100% going to rear end
somebody.
And she would also cite all the reasons and point to her brother
and say, "Yeah, like none of the kids turned out, you know, whatever."
Just at the exact right time, somebody's going to make a small
joke in his chat and he's going to go to argue against it. Emotional
dysregulation. Yes. Yes. Yes. That's what I meant. Uh yeah, somebody's
going to make a joke in his chat about a small He's going to
like look over at it, hit the gas when he sees traffic moving.
There's going to stop and he's going to ram into the back of
somebody. Right. At one point it was like 0 for three for them.
Luckily for them now it's two for three. But I would argue and
she would say this is abusive or gaslighting that the plus one
that Caitlyn represents that ratio that was at least in part
me when I met her. She was making under $25,000 a year and there
was no future.
I didn't think was he helping like really really really significantly
with princess party planning. I thought that was her business
for quite a while. I made $90,000 a year free bonus. And she
would run around telling all her friends I was. Dude, I see I
see so many of my chatters in here just talking. Nick, you're
lucky she didn't op herself listening to you yap and yap non-stop
day and night like a icy bob. And then Nick is here roughly 4
to 6K a month if he gets 1k views. So 1k views if he consistently
gets 1k views. So he needs to talk to kick and get KCIP. Her
rich boyfriend and then rich husband.
We were just like maybe upper middle class. Anyways, going back
to it, 457 days, not a single day, not a single day did she greet
me when I came home from work.
I don't want to hear this.
I I swear to God. Is there any way to prevent this in like your
I don't know. This is eated at this at him. not eated, but ated
him for like eight years. This is eight years going on. This
is true. And I'll give you my version and I'll give you her version.
Three months into us being married, I come home from work. I
come home from work. Like, he's going way too fast right now.
And like, yeah. Oh, wait. No, it won't happen cuz cars save you
now. Oh, cars are too smart, right? All cars have the thing and
they just automatically break for you. Ah, we're never going
to I asked her, "How was your day?" She goes, "Oh, not much."
Dude, you can tell he's like literally not paying attention.
Like just watch his vehicle here. Watch how fast he's going.
From work and watch where he starts slowing down. And like I
asked her, "How was your day?" That's 100% his vehicle slowing
down, right? She goes, "Oh, not much." I don't sound so disappointed.
Well, I don't want anybody to get hurt, but entertainment would
be funny. I don't want him to go like flying into somebody and
hurt somebody. Did you do anything? Yeah, it's probably better.
I don't wish for him to get in a car accident. That's true. She
goes, "Eh, not much." And I was like, "I mean, you know, you
have all the time in the world. You should do something, right?
Read a book, you know, see a movie, you know, do something, right?"
Like, like the world is literally your oyster. Like, you're living
a life that like most people don't get to live. You're not even
doing any housework
whatsoever. You just have to eight hours a day fully funded,
right? And so then she would start to like say, "Okay, well,
I'll do this thing, right?" And she would set her own little
goal, right? Her own valition. It wasn't mine. It was hers. That's
great, right? Well, hold on, Ally. I do want like I want him
like penalized for not paying attention to the road, but I don't
want him to get like hurt or anything, obviously. I thought like
a a rear end when like some when traffic starts up and then you're
not paying attention, you like hit the gas without looking and
then you rear end somebody. That's normally like a fender bender.
I don't Yeah, I don't want people to die obviously. It went none
of that. But then I realized this is at 3 months in, she never
even did the thing that she wanted to do that she said she was
going to do. And I was like, "What the hell?" Right? Like she
was trying to start a business, but there's like business bookings
and emails she wasn't answering. I was like, "What are you doing?"
Right? And then one day, I don't remember how I noticed it's
like I I don't remember if I came home one day or if it was like
a half day at work. It was probably like a half day and then
it was like a holiday and so we got out early, right? I came
home early than usual and like uh you know I walk in the house,
of course she's not there to greet me, you know, that's usual
and then I go to where she's sitting on the couch and the TV's
on, right? And like the way I the way I enter the house and the
living room, it's in a way that like basically
um I'm coming up from behind her from behind the couch. Not intentionally.
It's just the way the garage is located, right? Or where the
garage is situated. Okay. I'm walking up to her. She's like clearly
deeply engaged. Deeply engaged. Oh. In
a Facebook messaging session. And I didn't think anything of
it. That's not true. It's clearly It's clearly like a flashb.
I did casually ask who's that? X.
I assumed it was like one of her cosplaying uh girlfriends, right?
It was Kelly Jean. This is when Nick first learned about Kelly
Jean, his mortal enemy, Kelly Jean. Cuz Kate does not have very
many guy friends, at least back then. Well, hold on. Let me think
about that for a second. I guess she had girlfriends that were
closer and then a wider kind of circle of guy friends that were
like
Noah. Tanabomb says it was Marcus. No, it was probably Joe Marcus.
Okay. Acquaintance level. She would say she had more guys and
girlfriends, but when I look at like true friends, like people
you could tell anything to, I would say she has more girlfriends,
but whatever. Um, I just assumed it was one of her closer like
girlfriends, but no, it was a guy, a cosplay guy, and they were
like a hot guy. Keep in conversation. And she's like, "Oh, it's
nobody." I was like, "What? Like you can't tell me who it is?
I was kind of just in justest saying that, right? And she was
like, "No, it's just some guy." I was like, "Just some guy, you
know, you know, how do you where do you know him from? Cuz you
stay home all day." And she's like, "Oh, you know, like uh Instagram."
I was like, "Instagram." Okay. Right. And that was that for then.
Couple of months later, I came home again. There's another such
situation either uh you know either there was like a shut down
at the uh at the site or something like that and I came home
early and same thing keep in mind every day okay she's not cleaning
she's not doing anything okay and I was just wondering how could
someone just randomize same almost exact situation Nick is actually
furious because he took all of this time off of work he spent
all of his vacation time praying that she was getting railed
by some dude and she came home He came home every time and she
was just watching Pokémon or something. He's never felt more
betrayed in his entire life. I see her talking to the same dude.
At this point, I'm like, "Yo, what the is going on?" Like, you
literally talked to this guy like 100 times more than you talk
to me. Like, what in the ever loving? Right? Cuz I'm just like,
"Dude, like you do nothing to contribute to any of this, right?
Your main contribution is spending like seven to eight hours
chatting with this dude." And this is when she starts getting
defensive. And she goes, I do not talk to him that much. I go
like, it's weird that like both times I come home early, you
are though, right? Exactly the same situation, you know. And
she's I do not talk to him that much. And so I said, fine, show
me. And this is where it gets weird. She does the thing where
she keeps keep making sure that her back is not towards me and
that I can't see her phone screen. Like very obviously just moving
like sideways sometimes. I was like, "What the are you doing?"
She's like, "No thing. What are you talking about?" And after
like 3 minutes of this, she hands me the phone and I I look at
the message and it's like, "Oh, she messaged him one time today."
And then I scroll down to 5 days ago, 10 days ago. She deleted
me. 7 to 8 hours. It's not like Oh, wait. No, she every minute,
but it's like, you know, the longest gap is like 25 to 30 minutes,
but for seven to eight hours. So, you're talking like Okay, here's
the thing. If it's your wife, this might be something to be like
reasonably upset about. Okay, maybe might be okay to be reasonably
upset about it. But like if you think about it as if it was your
kid, in which case, you know, you said your wife has no experience,
no whatever. If you just put your kid at home all day every day
with nothing to do but just be on the internet, wouldn't you
expect some like this to happen? Like, yeah, your wife has like
nothing she's doing. Like, I'm I'm sorry. You shouldn't accept
partners like that. I'm sorry. Don't accept partners like that.
That is weird. There just accept a partner who has nothing. They're
not going to do anything at all. Like, and I'm not saying like
obviously um there's value in like having a a wife who does work
around the house, but if it if it's like he said and she literally
does no cooking, no cleaning, no nothing ever, right? And I'm
not talking about when she's sad or something. I'm saying like
consistently all the time. Even when she's super happy, just
nothing. It's like, yeah, why why accept that? Why the would
you accept that? That's weird. Yeah. 20 or 30 messages a day.
Okay. Now look, maybe it's proactively told me. Isn't this the
infantilization Kelly was talking about, Jtock? Yeah. Unfortunately,
he married a woman who's basically a child. Okay. He is a He
is a spiritual. Okay. He He married a woman who apparently acted
like a 13-year-old all day. That's not my fault. That's his fault.
Could have been different.
Okay. Maybe I think it's still, but like, you know, maybe it
could be like considered slightly different, right? And it was
at this point when I see the other messages that she goes, "He's
gay." Now, if you guys know Caitlyn and Nick Lure, you'll know
that at one point when there was a simp in her chat early in
her stream career that was donating a lot of money, and that
person asked who I was, cuz I used to be the camera guy at the
time, you know, this is like 2015 or she told that guy that Nick
was her gay friend or something like that, right? 2016 and it
stuck with him to this day. And the guy and so when she did IRL
streams, I'd have to hold her camera for her cuz it was just
me and her. And she wasn't making enough money to have any staff.
Once a very high donator asked, "Who's the guy holding your camera?"
And she I I'll never forget this, okay? Cuz this was like a year
after she would say, "You guys ready? You guys ready?" Oh, he's
just a gay guy. There's something about someone who can say that
lie about their husband. Wait, that makes it that they're messaging
all day. We're back. You know what I'm saying? A little bit,
right? A little bit. What can you do? And so I'm I'm giving y'all
a lot of deep lore about me and her. This is deep lore. It is
deep lore. Like maybe me, her, and like a knows about all this
cuz I, you know, this is why, you know, she always makes fun
of me for saying I care about her, not disrespecting me publicly,
but like I really closely safeguard her reputation. I have not
told anyone this. There's not a single guy friend I've ever told
this to. You guys are the first ears. First fresh set of n Wait,
what? Hold on. No, the gay friend. How did I know? What do you
mean were the first set of ears? What? Wait, what did I miss?
I missed something. Hold on. I thought he just said he's the
first person he told the story for, too. And I'm like, I'm giving
y'all a lot of deep lore about me and her. Deep lore. Deep lore.
This isn't deep. I literally I You watched me literally predict
it. How could the How could it possibly be deep lore?
like maybe me her and like a knows about all this. Well, you
know who told us this, right? You guys remember who told us this?
Yeah, hold on. If you know, put the emote in chat. If you know
who told us about this, put the emote in chat right now. Right
now, it is I, you know, this is why, you know, she always makes
fun of me for saying I care about her not disrespecting me publicly,
but like I really closely safeguard her reputation. I have not
told anyone this. There's not a single guy friend I've ever told
this to. You guys are the first ears, first fresh set of nonlicicensed
counselor ears on this matter. Okay. So, anyways, at this point,
you know, I hand her a phone back and I go, "Phone is slinging.
Phone is linging. Pick up your phone. Pick up your phone now."
So, I'm going to ask you a question, Kate. And I swear to God,
every word of this is true. Every word. Especially the next few.
Dude, I the gay the gay story or whatever. That's like um that
is not a new story. That is not at all this almost verbatim.
It's been 10 years or sorry I guess like 8 years something like
that. So it's not exactly verbatim but it's like these this situation
these these scenes are burned into my heart. I literally asked
"Caitlyn, can you ask can you tell me why you deleted the messages
from today when I asked you to see the messages?" And she goes,
"I didn't delete." I was like, "Caitlyn, you've been messaging
this guy consistently for like months, like two or 3 months easily,
like roughly the same amount of time every day. You're saying
just today it wasn't." She's like, "I didn't delete any messages."
I was like, "Then why'd you do that weird crab walk?
Why was it so imperative that I not see your phone screen?" and
she doubled down, triple down, quadruple down, quintupled down.
And finally, I said, "Listen, Caitlyn, if you tell me the truth,
now I'm just going to drop it and pretend like you told me right
what I asked, but please, you're you're starting to sound like
a compulsive liar. I know you deleted them. I know that it is
literally like I I have no relevant rated with 42
Let's uh don't forget really, we're live on Twitch as well. I'm
just kidding. But thank you very much. Oh, wait. That was on
Twitch base. We got a rally raid on Twitch. That's our first
Twitch raid since we've been streaming on Twitch since we've
been back. Oh my god. Welcome a relevant raiders. We are covering
the latest Nick Lee versus Amaranth drama. That's so awesome.
I haven't gotten a raid on Twitch like ever. That's so cool.
Thank you very much, Rei. That's what I was more excited about.
We get some new people in on Twitch. I heard Re had a panel tonight.
I wonder how that went. Doubt in my mind. So, you're not changing
my opinion one iota. The only opinion you're going to change
to me is if I can trust you or not. Oh, hello. It went well.
Oh, nice. Did you win? Did you prove that? Uh, if I listen, if
I say so myself, I think I won. Okay. All right. Well, had a
couple offshoot debates, man. People are too comfortable saying
they are cool with the kidnapping of civilians. It's too It's
too crazy, man. Yeah. Oh, you I saw you were debating Ogre Boy,
I think. Yeah. Um that guy's like pretty good. I think that guy
would be good for um like I I like he's like in my community
a lot and I think um like he stands on business and he's got
a lot of the like lefty opinions. So he's like good to talk to.
He did not stand on business in my conversation. Holy
Oh my god. I kept asking him very directly, do you is it justified
to kidnap civilians? And he kept going, "Well, um, well, why
are they kidnapping civilians?" I'm like, "Is it justified, dude?"
And he just he would not answer my questions. He would always
go like, "Ah, it's crazy." But, you know, Oh, I see what you're
saying. Yeah. Yeah, I see what you're saying. Um, yeah. I just
for me the Houthy thing like I I don't know. There's probably
you could probably get me some hypothetical where kidnapping
civilians would be like possibly acceptable, right? Like I'm
sure there's a hypothetical that exists, but I would say just
as a general rule, it like it is a good rule to have. And in
the Hooie situation, they gained literally nothing by keeping
those civilians. They sorry, they gained nothing that wasn't
like basically like um like morally black, you know, morally
evil to do. Like you've kidnapped these civilians and you could
trade them technically for like supplies or something or money.
You could technically, but then you're just kidnapping civilians
to ransom them. like the actual damage to Israel's economy. Let's
say if you like if you steal the Galaxy leader and you like keep
that from running and there's an Israeli billionaire who owns
it. Let's say that's all true. Like okay, fair fair play maybe.
But like the civilians were unrelated. They don't even get paid
very much by the the company that hires them. Yeah.
Like no no advantage keeping them. Yeah. In terms of stopping
the genocide in terms of just negotiating for like money or something
or lifting sanctions. Sure. But yeah. Yeah, I don't like it.
It's It's very weird. I don't like how comfortable people are
with saying it. Yeah, I just I think it's a pretty easy line
to draw as just um unrelated civilians can't be attacked ever.
Related civilians could maybe possibly be like collateral damage
like civilians who are, you know, like the civilian force of
the IDF or something or something similar to that. I maybe they
could be collateral damage or something. But yeah, to me it's
just um Hold on. I need to suppress alerts in this. Uh okay.
Yeah, like I don't know. most unrelated civilians. Like there's
some argument that like uh how do I put this? Maybe I should
just ask more questions first. I was just I wanted to talk to
people about this the the Israel Palestine stuff. So what were
people saying about uh the the diplomat shooting? You talked
to many people about that. Newbie came in and there was another
individual and they were I feel like we got a little bit in the
weeds, but an issue was about uh uh how the rhetoric can like
contribute to the ecosystem that that that shooter kind of comes
from, right? But he can feel justified in with the very es excal
escalatory rhetoric.
people are going to feel justified doing things like that because
you know people are saying stuff like we need to peaceful protest
isn't working we need to escalate and then also um with people
again just brazenly accepting the idea yeah it's actually totally
fine in the name of Gaza to kidnap people I don't think somebody
taking it a step further and saying physical violence against
people is going to be like oh man I couldn't imagine how that
could be done no obviously if you're talking about like targeting
civilians for political goals being justified. Somebody is going
to just add the the next leap there. Yeah. Yeah. Um
so let me see. I think that I agree but what what should really
be highlighted by these people who believe in these causes is
that like ex allowing your extremists to get violent is basically
like how you turn into like competing terrorism. It's literally
how Israel Palestine started more or less, right? Was extremists
on both sides were doing terrorist attacks against each other.
It's literally how they got the occupation, right? Takes over
starts growing in power in the Gaza Strip. They start bombing
Israel. Um and then the occupation starts. They go and they like
basically blockade the Gaza Strip. Yeah. Yeah. Like literally
just doing like indiscriminate of civilians to cause terror is
how you embolden the the extremists on the other side and how
you make normal people go, "Okay, my extremists are fine, you
guys." Yeah. Right. So, it just doesn't work. As a tactic, it
fails. So, that's really what people should focus on. As a tactic,
it basically always fails. I I understand totally. I'm sympathetic
on an emotional or empathetical uh empathetic level. Maybe I
should say I'm empathetic to the idea that they terrorize civilians.
Israel terrorizes civilian. I want people who support Israel
to be terrorized. I understand how you get there emotionally.
It's just logically you have to, you know, put on your human
thinking cap and go, "Oh, but it basically always leads to bad
outcomes." Just doesn't work. Yeah.
That's how I feel about it. I agree. Um, now I the only thing
I would argue is I do not believe there's sufficient proof that
this was motivated by anti-semitism yet. Uh, yeah. I haven't
I haven't seen sufficient proof that it's Yeah. the hatred of
Jewish people that motivated it.
Yeah. Yeah. Other than that. Okay. Was that Did you hit any of
those points in the panel? Uh yeah. Well, I mean they agreed
that like it's just like bad for the movement. It's like there's
a large crackdown on pro Palestinian speech. So the pedal was
about rhetoric. That's what it was about was like the rhetoric
specifically pro Palestinian rhetoric possibly enabling this
type of behavior and it's just like yeah this this type of rhetoric
is is just bad for pro Palestinian people because the Trump administration
or whoever people are going to use it to justify cracking down
on pro Palestinian speech more. Um yeah what's next I the Nick
stuff? Oh, he's like in his car. He's like going to therapy and
he's just talking about his wife like basically the whole time.
He's on his way to therapy talking about his wife.
Yeah. Yeah. Basically, I'm still on a slot. Thank you for the
five gifted. Let's go. Yeah. He's like basically talking about
how basically they used to agree that like her parents did a
poor job raising her and now he's like, "Okay, actually like
what do you say?" He's like, "It's either bad parenting or she's
just a bad person." That's the only options. Those are the only
options.
Yeah. So he's he's driving to therapy, his wife. I think he's
about to be late for therapy and we'll see. They have like a
whole blow up today around around their therapy and it's pretty
funny. Okay. I I have one question for you as the resident scholar
of this fiasco. Yeah. Listen, no glaze. Okay. No sing.
I based on what I've seen, it seems like 90% of the abusive behavior
is coming from Nick.
Can you do away with that illusion? Uh, no. I would just say
that you don't. Here's the problem is I would say 90 That's probably
true. But like 90% of the abusive behavior, how could you put
it? Like maybe on stream is him, but also she streamed like 20
hours a day. So like like realistically, unfortunately, he's
like, "Well, you don't see us off stream." And I'm like, "Well,
I don't think you guys see each other off. I assume you sleep
at some point, right?" Yeah.
like you guys stream basically 20 hours a day. It seems like
most of your behavior is on stream. So, I don't know. Yeah. Yeah.
No, I I just wanted to make sure I wasn't popping in at his like
worst moments, his like worst highlights cuz what I've seen is
she seems to be very like debate broy in a like toxic way with
her partner with Nick. But like that's I would say that's a learned
behavior and also that's like a new behavior that didn't really
exist maybe like um like three months ago like that right after
the robbery that behavior didn't exist at all. That behavior
like wasn't there her getting debate bro? No, she would like
very often she would just say like I don't really understand
and then she'd go like from I don't understand to like you know
what you're right and I just don't get it and just try to like
start deescalating start trying to stop the uh the argument and
he would just keep debate broing and then eventually she started
kind of losing it and debate broing back. So, oh yeah, that's
that's the only thing that I saw where I was like, okay, the
way that she's like debate drawing, she's not really giving him
very much space for like his emotions or or like explaining himself.
She It feels like she's like trying to quip and get like dunks.
But, um the uh what you call it uh you said it was like a learn
behavior or whatever. Well, I think well learn behavior or like
evolve behavior like as in it wasn't working when she was trying
to deescalate so she kind of just eventually started like hitting
him back. Yeah. There's only so much to be done I guess about
that then.
Yep. Yep. Yep. It's um I would say now now I wouldn't I don't
know if that's abusive. That's more like going back and forth.
Although she does talk about him a little bit. You tell he was
arguing with his chat about his size. Yeah. His chat was making
fun of his little dick and he was like some of us are growers.
It's "Bro, don't don't don't entertain them." And then he started
talking about how what did he say? She was like, he was like, "Yeah,
she complains about my size, but also her orififices are really
tight." Was a quote, I believe, nearly verbatim.
Oh my god, bro. There's no shots. Cuz the complaint she has shot,
man, apparently is that she can't open her mouth wide enough
to blow him. And he's like, "If my dick was any bigger, that
would be worse." Proven. He was like, "I proved it." Because
apparently one of the complaints he has is toothy She's like,
"Well, I can't open my mouth bigger." I don't, Dude, I know too
much about these people's lives. Okay. I Yeah, I was about I
was literally about to say it's not weird that he said that.
It's weird that you're remembering all of these details. Hey,
bro. He's into bro. Okay. Like 10 minutes ago in this VOD, I'm
not joking. He started telling this story about how um how Amaranth
was talking to him about some other co to some other cosplay
guy and he's like talking about it and I'm like oh here here
it comes. She called him like her gay friend who was the cameraman
and he like tells the story and that's the story. It's like I'll
never forget this in my entire life. She said I was her gay friend.
She said I was just a gay guy. I'll never forget that. And I'm
like, "Oh, that's crazy that I like I I this guy downloaded."
I'm in his head. And then two seconds later, he's like, "Also,
this is like deep lore. I've never told a guy friend about that
at all. I don't think anyone knows that story." And I'm like,
"Wait, I know that story. How how the do what? What? Kelly knew
that story. So maybe maybe Emran told that story in cosplay circles
or something, but Kelly told me about that story like a long
time ago." Oh no. Yeah. So yeah, I don't know. I will say now
she starts to like joke about his like small and it's uh it is
like bordering on mean but it's hard to necessarily defend him.
He's kind of been an you know I mean probably shouldn't make
fun of there should be some limits to the humiliation. There
really should be. There should be some limits for sure. Indeed.
Oh man. Yeah. Why do you look like a like a Hawaiian arms dealer
in your It's like a It's like a Nick outfit. This is like one
of Nick's outfits. my logo. Is it really? It has like guns and
it's yellow like that. Yes. Yes. Oh. Oh, your aimbot is showing
on stream. Yeah. Yeah. I was I just switched to a different one.
Switched to a different Nick. And then I have like the Penguin
version. Hold on. Was it Nick Penguin? Nick Penguin. Nick Penguin.
Where's my Nick Penguin? Nick Penguin. And this is Oh,
it's just a Penguin. I love the Penguin so much. It's the best.
It's pretty good. It's pretty good. What the else has been going
on? I'm trying to think of like politics stuff. What have we
been checking out recently? Not that one. There we go.
I mean, the House was pushing forward some cringe. So, there's
the the bill that's getting moved forward. We'll see how the
Senate reacts. Yeah. Yeah. The big beautiful budget bill.
Yes. Quadruple B. Oh, also clock on his dash. People are getting
triggered by the clock. Yeah. Watch it. It counts up seconds
all the time. She paused for like 10 15 seconds that felt like
way longer. Just looks like a speedometer or something. Yeah.
What? What? Why would you have a clock like that in your car?
I don't know. I've seen I've seen a Buick My parents had a Buick
once that had a clock like this, but it was way smaller and it
was like clearly a clock cuz it had Roman numerals on it and
Yep. Yep. Yep. What was the uh what was the craziest position
you heard on that
Uh
uh the Everybody was pretty reasonable. Um, for a second it sounded
Doobie. Uh, but it sounds like he kind of went away from it.
Um, but it was like Doobie said that somebody who was
speak. Thank you. Thank you. I'm not sure I remember it exactly,
but effectively it sounded like what Dubbie was saying, well,
what Doobie did say was that anybody who supports Israel,
right, um is supporting genocide is a genocide supporter. And
um or has positive sentiment, Israeli sentiment is a genocide
supporter.
Um, and then off of that, it sounded like he what he said was
anybody with uh uh like who's like pro- genocide has
uh the right to get like it is justified to smack them. Yeah,
but I believe what he clarified and that perhaps I misheard
he was saying that somebody who's like knowingly pro- genocide,
like somebody who's like, "Yeah, I actually want Palestinians
to be genocide should be smacked." Very different. Yeah, it's
a it's a different thing. Yeah. Gotcha. Crazy. Crazy.
It was relatively tame. It was more of just disagreements about
whether or not uh uh like the rhetoric is a big deal. And they
kept saying, "Well, if if you want like crazy stuff like this
to stop happening, you shouldn't look too much at the rhetoric
that people are saying. You should look at Israel to stop the
war." And I'm like, "Well, you know, we as individuals can't
just stop the war on our own, but I think we can hold people
to a higher standard for their rhetoric." Yeah, makes sense.
So, yeah. I just uh I just found this guy out in chat. Told him
he can join VC if he wants to get untimed out. He's calling you
a Zionist
bootlicker. Hey, I'm trying to see. Yeah, I'm trying to see if
he'll hop in. Maybe he'll hop in the callins and defend his opinion.
I don't know what it's based on. I get the teeth
I I can't get my teeth chattering on the the mic. We'll see if
that guy joins. I don't I don't think so. I kind of doubt it.
Most people are pretty not down to ever join anything ever. Yeah,
it happens almost all the time. It's like so boring. I just I
wish people would join and just argue. That's why that's maybe
the reason I would want Tik Tok or YouTube streaming right now
is basically just to like you can find new people and but if
you build up like an audience, you like kind of wean out people
who want to argue over time and so eventually people just don't
want to hop in really anymore.
I don't know. It's kind of rough emote maybe. I'm trying to I'm
still trying to get to be able to stream on Tik Tok. It's so
cringe. They won't let me. And they're like, "Hey, you need to
verify your age." And they still won't let me verify my age.
I've had an open ticket on Tik Tok for a week and they haven't
messaged me about it. Okay. Well, yeah. Hold on. How big is your
Tik Tok account? Because it's probably way bigger than mine.
Nothing. Like 100 followers.
They do let you. Okay. It's not massively bigger than mine, but
it's like uh around the same followers, but you have content
posted at least. I don't really have content posted, unfortunately.
Oh, you should farm you should farm this if you farm if you farm
Dean. I feel like farming Dean could be the way to go. You see,
Tom had demon is Dean is in his uh Tik Tok chat or whatever.
Yeah, I dude, you know what's funny? I was literally messaging
John or or Tom, sorry, before that all went down, before he had
Ryan Beer before this because I was like, "Yo, let's tag team
this." He's like, "Yeah, let's go for this." And I that's what
invoked my attempt to go live on TikTok. We
liter all of that. But they're me, dude.
They're me. It's so annoying, man. But now it feels so old. Now
it feels like old news. I know it's not, but it feels like old
news. But I wanted to get in that. I specifically wanted to get
in there, man. That's That is tough, dude. That is really tough
when fought with. Yeah, but but Dean didn't join, did he?
I don't think he joined. I think he was asking to join and I
think Tom said something like, "Yo, you're not going to get allowed
in here because I don't know. I actually don't know. I think
he wanted him to debate Destiny or
Bro, how that's yourself so hard, dude. If you farmed I don't
know. I'm I'm not going to Don't hard quote me on that. Don't
hard quote me. I truly do not know. I just think I saw on Twitter
somewhere him saying like making fun of him for not talking to
Destiny.
That's crazy. Well, I know he did he did say like something about
him not talking Well, hold on. Actually, I think I have a tweet
here somewhere or it will it'll just be on the top of his timeline
here. Let me check it. Let me check it out real quick. Is it
uh No, not this one. Wait, it isn't. Is it that one? No, this
one. Of this energy for Destiny. Dean Withers begs to come on
my live stream. Why don't you all have this energy? Yeah, that's
what I saw. Because that they're scared of Destiny. Yeah, if
Dean's coming here to talk to me yet refusing to talk to Destiny,
the Oh, that would be unproductive, I think, is what Parker said.
if he wants to debate you. Dude, there's no way that he like
he actually just like canceled himself to help Destiny. Oh, there's
a guy in the waiting room. It might be the guy we timed out.
Do you want me to pull him in? This is the guy who debated a
minute ago on my stream. Wait, it's not the same guy. Hold on.
No, no, no.
Oh, it's Oh, hold on. I was talking to somebody I timed out that
was like, "Hey, you can come in if you uh get timed out." Wait,
was What was that? That's not him. I see. That's not the same
guy. I don't think so. I see. But I did just debate these retired.
What did he argue? Wait, hold on. He argued that it was justified
to kidnap civilians and he also kind of kept rambling about other
stuff.
Hold on. What's up, dude? How's it going? It's going okay. How
about you? Pretty good. How do you justify civilians? Kidnapping
civilians? Sorry. Uh, no. I don't justify kidnapping civilians.
Uh, if you're talking about we're rewriting history, are we?
Okay. No, no. What do you What do you think I said? Like someone
someone else you and Ogre extremely deliberately is it justified
to kidnap civilians and this is what I said and I I someone in
chat said that it wasn't me as well, but whatever. I I have Maybe
it wasn't. Maybe I am. Maybe I'm misremembering you. Maybe I
have a response. I don't justify it. But let's take the the ship
for example. the the civil the uh workers the crew that was kidnapped
for like 14 months, right, for multiple countries.
Um uh and not even on an Israeli ship. So, I'll be real. It's
kind of like Houthies kind of making themselves look a little
silly, I will admit, because it wasn't really that connected
to Israel. Like, Israel is probably like, "We don't give a that
much about that." But it, you know, it's it is what it is. They're
definitely way smaller, so whatever. Um but the idea is how do
you ensure not only the safety the safe transition of those hostages
or just the crew potentially is the way to look at it to an area
um or back to the countries or wherever you know cuz it's a it's
in the middle of the ocean right
um without like endangering them or endangering the operation
like let like getting rid of the ship like you have physically,
you know, transport these individuals, right? So, you either
put them on the ground. Now, granted, they could have been left
let led off the ship, right? But you understand they have a port
and the UN like ships food to them. See, there is that. But the
thing is, how would they essentially ensure that they will continue
to be able to stay alive as well? You can give them food, put
them on a lifeboat. There's life. I'm not I'm not talking about
the civilians. I'm talking about them on the ship. Who on the
ship? The Houthies. How do they ensure their own safety instead
of getting bombed by US and Saudi Arabia as has been happening
continually? You just want them to use civilians that they've
kidnapped as shields. Is that what you're saying? Not shields
because if they were shields then they would expect them to,
you know, it would be like a shield, right? Like they would die
and the other and they wouldn't, right? Like that's not a shield.
that's essentially going like, "Hey, we're not going to treat
you like, but we want to not die and we want to counteract, you
know, the other Islamic people." Uh, so like we're going to we're
going to be peaceful to you. Sorry about the literally you're
actually you're you're doing like a distinction here, which like
totally does away the metaphor. They're like words. They're using
them defensively, saying, "Hey, I have something that you value.
If you shoot me, okay, I'm I'm covered in babies right now. If
you shoot me, you're going to hit one of these babies. You could
say it's not a shield literally as in it doesn't stop a bullet.
Yeah, a baby doesn't stop a bullet. But it stops from somebody
from shooting. That's the point of the shield in that. Okay.
So don't say like no it's not a shield when yeah we both understand
exactly we both understand exactly what's being said there. It
needs it needs to be understood as not a shield. It's essentially
saying hey
lives right. It's significantly worse than a shield. It
shields is my point. I'm taking your baby and using it so that
you'll kill both of us if you shoot me. That is like morally
worse than than using my shield. That's like morally worse. Know
who these eyes even like I already I hope you understand that
like calling it a shield is actually doing you a favor. You should
just let us call you a shield. You're taking unrelated civilians
and using them uh to block somebody from taking shots at you.
Like no and want to quite literally clarify that it's not a shield.
Like you have to understand that that's not what it is. Like
I understand you see it as that, right? Like you see it as that
metaphorical shield, but they are quite literally if there was
a different way to ensure their safety, you know, like the US
didn't like bomb regularly these ships. I just want you to understand
these lives for example. They're essentially justifying kidnapping
civilians 100%. So when you said you didn't justify kidnapping
civilians, you've come in here and completely justified kidnapping
civilians. I think that is justifying it before kidnapping. Wow.
It is justifying it. Hold on. Hold on. Why did Why did the Houthies
keep them? Why Why did the Houthies keep them? Why did the Houthies
kidnap them? The Houthies kept them on the ship in order Well,
they didn't do any exchange. So, I would just say in order to
ensure their safety on the ship. Yes. So, the justification for
kidnapping those people is to justification. That's explanation.
If you think that is justification, then you do not understand
how to talk about these topics. These topics, we have to be real
about those people. Those people are doing those operations for
reasons. I'm not justifying anything. You say that again and
like over and over. Do you support that? Do you support that?
Do you support that? Do you support them doing what they have
to do to stay alive? I support any peaceful measure, but no,
I wouldn't do that. So, no, I'm not do that. That's not what
I asked you. I sympathizers. Sympathizers are not supporters
are not justifiers. You need to understand the difference. Actually,
that's why I'm asking you to say you condemn them for doing this.
Man, that's pathetic as condemn them. I am not them. Do you not
No. One minute. You need to let me finish if you actually want
to hear an answer. If you don't condemn it, you're explaining
why you are saying and you are giving a justification. No, you
are not do you are just trying to make your point only. You're
not trying to understand the situation at all. It's so freaking
frustrating because you all don't. Then shut the up for a second.
Exactly what you're saying. I'm giving you the exact precise
language that you need to prove that you're not justifying it.
I'm saying if you condemn it, then you don't support it in any
way. You say you think you
know more than me freaking what? You think that you tell me that
the only I only won't justify them if I condemn them rather than
say, "Hey, when people are desperate for, you know, saving people
that they care about's lives, they try some desperate situations.
It's not good, but I'm not them close to the situation. I have
the privilege. It's still bad. Shut the up." Like, holy, you
said the same thing to interrupt me every time. What's the point
of doing that, man? Like, that's just useless as to interrupt
someone with the same point. That's wrong and you know it, dude.
I literally just said how it's not. Can you explain what I just
said? Explain what I just said or I ain't listening. You said
that when people are very scared for their lives, when they're
trying to protect the things that are important around them,
they will take any measures they can to protect their lives,
including up to and including kidnapping civilians. And while
you think that's wrong, you're not going to condemn them for
it. You don't think it's good. Correct. How is that justifying?
Because if you are saying you are saying it is justified that
you are saying you are saying literally like it is I'm not going
to condemn them for doing that. Okay, let me explain. Do you
know what the radicalization ladder is or the pyramid is? I don't
care. Can you just tell me what you can't say that you you only
I literally don't care. Just tell me. Can you just broation?
I just want you to tell me what you think justification means
for for us. I'm literally about I'm literally about to. And you
just don't want to listen. So shut up. You know what? I I sat
my white ass down. I'm listening. All right. The radicalization
letter pyramid has justification as one of the areas. It is the
third ring up. The bottom is neutral. That's like usually everybody.
People who don't care. The second is what I am. an activist,
a sympathizer with the cause, but I advocate and do peaceful
action. I don't make content for violent action. I usually this
I usually dradicalize violent action. Actually, I was actually
doing it in the chat. For example, like I even have arguments
and dialogue to try to dradicalize El Alasan. Why is violent
action bad? Why do you advocate against violent action? because
violent action towards civilians especially does not really get
the results that we need. It usually creates power vacuums. Uh
um more murder of other civilians as has been seen recently.
And typically, yes, most of condemns it as well, but you all
think that they don't. All of the pieces here to say that it's
bad and to say you condemn the action. You don't have to condemn
the group, but you condemn the action of kidnapping the civilians.
You have everything there. See, you think that's condemning?
You put it all together. What do you mean by condemning? No,
I didn't say you were condemning. I said you should be able to
condemn. You just explained why you should condemn that action.
No, I explained why that's not effective. No, you explained Yes.
The Houthies are literally taking steps that are not supporting
their own goals. They are doing very inefficient, ineffective
actions that are only harming the people that they care about
and themselves. That's bad. It's definitely more efficient than
the US and Saudi Arabia's plan. So clearly the situation isn't
that simple because US and Saudi Arabia obviously have had a
lot of experience with you know imperialism war in these situations
but for some reason they have less peaceful methods. Like why
why do we not talk about that? Like I'm not close to that situation,
right? But at least it looks like to me one side's trying while
the other side's not and nobody wants to talk about that. Wait,
what what do you think about the Soviet Union? Really quickly,
I just quick
um depends on what um region, area, country you're talking about.
You can have you can have like two groups that are bad and they
can oppose each other and both can be bad. Sure. But here's the
thing. Soviet Union being the people who both are actually bad.
Do you think US all of us is bad doesn't make good even all of
US governance during those times? Do you think all of them were
bad? You you understand? I'm like literally telling you you don't
have to condemn the Houthies. I don't think you have to care.
Holy Answer that question. It's actually it's actually a good
point that I'm making. Ask your question. Do you think everybody
in the Soviet Union, every leader in the governance and every
leader in US governance and every leader in Chinese governance
and every colonialist leader ever, do you think all of them were
bad or all of them were complicated humans just like the rest
of us that probably tried to make what they saw as injustices?
Like actually, they're definitely all complicated humans. Why
are we talking about what kind of people they are when we are
actually just talking about actions that have been undertaken?
Because I said repeatedly that I didn't ask you to dis disavow
the Houthies. I said disavow them kidnapping those civilians,
keeping those civilians kidnapped for a year and a half. What
is their other option? What do you have? What do you say?
Basically have the UN ship food and then put those civilians
on that food container and send them back. Uh, Israel is destroying
food trucks and stifling food and also that's you know bare minimum
humanitarian aid. Israel is stifling food trucks and bombing
food trucks into Yemen. Well, sorry. But you food trucks into
Yemen. The ship was literally stopped because of Israel. This
ship was kidnapped because of Israel. So I thought you were talking
about Israel and Palestine. Okay. But yeah, sure. Yemen. Like
they were trying to help with Palestine. They more than just
themselves. They care about the whole region. So like they took
hostages off of that boat that they could have just thrown onto
some UN boat or some UN truck and said go back to go back with
them. The UN came in and and talked to these people. I think
was it six or eight months after they originally got kidnapped.
They could have gone back. Do you think they should have How
about this? How about this? Since you're not offering a different
solution. I kind of have one, but people hate this. What do we
need a different solution for? Hold on. What? What the Because
if we're going to condemn something, we can't just say, "Ooh,
bad." We have to give them an option because they're doing the
awful thing. Like I want to repeat this. I said that in chat.
I'm literally forgiving like 95% of their terrorism. I'm like
the boat. I kind of understand they're doing an awful disrupting
shipping for a good reason. All those things I kind of understand.
The kidnapping is not a good reason. The kidnapping is not affecting
the conflict. What else do they do to ensure their safety on
that boat? And I have a different reason. I have a different
uh No, not a different reason. I have a different goal uh or
different solution that has to do with the boat. I don't think
they kept the civilians on the boat the whole time. They didn't
keep most of the civilians on the boat. Yeah, I think it's because
they eventually saw that hey, they don't care that much about
the vote boat and they Yeah, I I don't know. I I have to look
into it further. Like there's always more to learn in reality.
Okay. So, you just So, your whole point you just made is not
true. What? Uh no. Um wasn't keeping you safe on the boat? No,
it was it's just like at that point they didn't think so. They
did it I think because they wanted to keep themselves safe, but
you know, maybe they realized, hey, they're not going to bomb
us uh currently um in this situation for whatever reason. I don't
really know like you know, like maybe they felt safe at that
point. Maybe they like finally decided they had to let the hostages
go and then dip or something, you know. Uh but anyway, what was
the point? But the point is they did something awful for a good
reason because something even worse was happening. So, if we're
going to condemn it, if you want to I gave the uh Yeah, I condemn
it. They should have sent They should have sent those Yes, they
should have sent those civilians back because they had already
done whatever economic harm they could and it was a massive victory,
massive PR coup for them, right? They'd already won every victory
they could. The only thing they could do now is put those human
beings next to things they didn't want bombed, hoping that it
would avoid them getting bombed. How? I do not believe that is
a morally justifiable act for any AR. I was stopping the ship
for a day. Like I assume you would want them like released on
the same day. How is stopping the ship for a day like a success?
That's not a success. You don't put them You don't put them on
the galaxy leader and let them take the galaxy leader away. You
keep the galaxy leader. You send them back on a UN ship or a
UN truck, whatever the drives into
uh SA. Yeah. But then they're not safe. Like I said, like in
their eyes potentially. The Houthies aren't Yes. So you want
you want the Houthis to for their safety to keep things close
to them that will prevent them from exploding. Human beings.
No, this is this is actually what I want. So, this is what I
would do personally. I would I hope you understand that that
is not an argument that I want to keep the unrelated civilian
next to me so I don't get bombed. That is not a that is not a
viable argument. What did you do? You realize what I just said
is no and I would do this instead. Or not I wouldn't do this,
but I would say this is a better You're going to do something
else instead. No. False. Good try trying to get me freaking uh
shimped because you think it's going to get you something from
like the police or something. I assume they usually harass me
for that reason, but like whatever. Like it's not going to work.
Like I literally talk to them all the time. You sniffed it out.
You avoided it. You know, I appreciate it. I was well done. Almost
got you. I almost got you for sure. Um anyway,
uh what would like Yeah. You know what? If I was part of the
Houthies, so a military gang, right? This is a hypothetical.
and I dradicalize wherever I am. Right. I really hate violence,
honestly. Awesome. So, this is what I would say. Yeah, we don't
have to kidnap them, at least not for long. We do have to take
over the ship. So, either way, they're going to be in our custody
for some period of time. Then, we plant bombs everywhere on this
material ship. Hopefully, just a commodity ship that destroys
Israel's treats so their people get mad at them more. Like, have
to focus on the news more. for example, right? Um that like that's
typically the strategy, at least in my eyes. Um
uh but then once they're off the ship, you give them to the others,
you get off the ship, and then you blow up the ship, and all
that productivity is gone. That ship is gone, and that is at
least more of an effective route uh than the others. But you
want to know something? According to international law, that
would indefinitely be terrorism. Wait, it was already terrorism.
They kidnapped like unrelated civilians. Kind of gets complicated
with with uh terrorism in that sense. They are a political it
is a politically motivated and big operation like a military.
So yeah, but technically it could get kind of interesting. Sure.
Morally by a moral definition of terrorism is literally terrorism.
Okay. Moral. Okay. like what kind of moral the most concrete
morals kind the kind of like moral definition that would make
the IDF a terrorist group is the definition I'm using that's
called law and pro that only that that that is very specific
potentially but probably yeah they would probably be called the
terrorist group yeah yeah but I'm saying this is terrorism you
kidnapped random civilians you could have there's an argument
for like there's there was some actual objective there the galaxy
leader okay so you're saying wait you put bombs on the galaxy
leader and then I actually lost After that, you put bombs in
the Galaxy Leader and then you send them back in a different
way or
you understand the Galaxy Leader like wasn't released, right?
As far as I know, they still have the Galaxy Leader, don't they?
Yeah, I know. Which is why I say the thing about they must have
uh realized that they didn't need the hostages anymore uh for
safety for whatever reason. Okay. Like I don't know. It's kind
of weird. It's kind of sus in fact in my opinion because that
kind of implies that it's not not really pressure which is you
know really the really messed up thing like it might also be
not very effective like these people don't have to care about
us like at the end of the day and if they're anything like Trump
they seem to not give a unless if they have enough money to be
able to give him a good life
unfortunately that's why I'm a communist hate money dude makes
it too easy to be an okay uh they freed the hostage There's a
one-mon ceasefire. Anything to do with that one month ceasefire
wire rope has nothing to do with those hostages. Israel don't
give a about those hostages. Ain't no country give a about those
hostages. If Israel is going to have the Hannibal doctrine and
blow up their own hostages before they're taken if that's a thing
that this country's ethos supported 20 years ago, then there's
no way they care about a random Filipino. I'm sorry. They don't
give a I 100% agree. Why the would any of those hostages help
pressure Israel in any way? I 100% agree. Which is probably why
they released them as well. Like they had no reason is probably
what they concluded. Yeah. But they did a year and a half. It
was
dude like you got to realize that like imagine arguing with a
military leader. I want you to imagine that, right? Like leadership
typically these things up, right? We don't have to think about
we don't actually have to think about convincing people to do
these things. Yes, you do.
No, we're talking about morality. We're talking about what's
right and wrong. Boo. Boohoo. Boohoo. Boo. You care about morality,
but I care about how people actually Here's the thing about ethics.
You have to think about what people are actually. You could just
separate them in your mind. You could literally just say this
is why this is why you really sound actually quite similar to
son right now, which I don't even I'm not even criticizing you
for, but there's just nothing gained by not saying kidnapping
civilians is bad. That is wrong. I did already say that it was
an it was a bad thing. Okay. But you have to follow the logical
entailment which is this action of kidnapping civilians is morally
wrong and you just want that is the problem. You don't want more
added to it. That is a huge problem y'all. Why is it a huge problem?
I'm not denouncing I'm not denouncing the other things that people
consider terrorism though. You understand? I'm not even denouncing
the group. I'm saying this one thing was ineffective and morally
wrong. So I'm going to condemn it. It's not effective. It's morally
wrong. That's bad. Yo, what do you Okay, I know this I know this
is going to sound you asked like why is that why is that a problem,
right? So, I want you to listen me hear me out for a second.
What do you think Republicans main strategy for the dialogue
of politics is or conservatives? Like what what are you talking
about? Just just just wait. Just ask just answer if you don't
have an answer. Pointing out wrongdoing pointing out wrongdoing
by the other side and focusing solely on that instead of any
positive policy looking. I would say this. I would say this and
voting rights is another good example. Uh freedom of speech uh
um uh what's it called? Hypocrisy and uh attacking is another
example. But I would say they want to reduce the dialogue as
much as possible. So when y'all do it as allies of us, I get
real because it's like yo, hold on. But every time you got one
piece
and I don't want to that context matters. Every time that context,
there is no that isn't the context that matters though. You could
you hold on. It makes you look insane to anybody who's listening
to you.
These are the things that get picked on and it literally doesn't
unlike actual civilian violence. This level of like
down is like civilian violence. It just doesn't work. It's so
ineffective. It makes you look ethics is op and this is definitely
ethical. I'm thinking about those human beings and how they have
to go through a situation where others are dying. That random
Filipino doesn't get to see his family for a year and a half.
Yeah, damn straight it doesn't. But that is not exactly how those
operations go. They didn't necessarily know. I'll be real. Israel
has a diversity of people. They saw those people as Israeli workers,
right? So in their eyes, they were connected to Israel. Yes,
they did. They thought it was You're talking about like the Filipino
people who got killed in Oh, no. You're No, they don't see the
Filipino people on that ship as Israeli. That ship is not sailing
from Israel,
from like Europe or something going through the No, they they
thought it was connected to Israel. So they saw them as Israeli
connected workers at the very least like maybe not directly Israel's
workers obviously but working for Israel like the same as like
if you have ever worked like internationally you have worked
with organizations look like Filipinos.
They don't they don't look anything alike. Okay. One that's very
racist. There's many different people in in Israel. Like just
saying um like what the heck like they're everywhere like in
the whole world globally forever like Genesis like the whole
point was to travel. So a lot of them did that. That's why the
idea of Israel is ridiculous to many. Okay. Whatever. Genesis.
What? What are you talking Why did you say Genesis?
Genesis. Do you know what Genesis is? Genesis. It like that's
like the whole point was that there's no way you're talking about
the first book of the Bible right now. Yes, I am. Okay. Did they
exist in the birth book of the Bible? Yeah. What the That was
that was them. Jesus was Is Jesus in Genesis? No. However, okay,
that there Yes, Jews were in Genesis. Abraham was Jewish. Maybe
I I literally don't know. That's why I asked maybe I thought
Abraham didn't come around until later, but maybe not. Jacob
was his name literally got changed after he wrestled with God
which just in my opinion I'm a naturalist so you know scientific
uh secular it just means that he wrestled with someone that almost
killed him and broke his hip. Yeah kind of cool but you know
it's cool they said wrestled with God um and he called himself
Israel after that and they had to find the land of Israel and
they killed the Canonite. Well his sons killed the Canaanites
for raping their sister. Like I'm just trying to saying all this
because this is essentially what a lot of this story is, right?
This is genocide. I was about to just talk about genocide in
guess what in Palestine. Historic Palestine. It's very frustrating.
Like sure, maybe that specific instance in Genesis didn't happen,
but in definitely it's been part of the dialogue for freaking
centuries at this point or not centuries, millennia at this point,
right? like very very frustrating that genocide has been justified
or part of the discussion for so long and we're still letting
it happen.
So yeah, it's very frustrating. What do you all do about that?
I hope peace. I hope to call out the UN for its hypocrisy essentially
and for them to actually grow some balls and like like push governments
and themselves to arrest these
uh uh international crimes. But you know, freaking UN's website
is UN.org, not.gov like every other freaking nation. Even though
it's international law, so clearly it's not respected even by
the
internet. Sorry, I'm fed up. I'm tired. Okay. All right. Well,
okay. I, you know, I have no rebuttal to that. Uh,
neither do I. And I don't know if it helps at all. Is the most
frustrating
Not yet. Slowly but surely we will win eventually. I know that
for a fact.
But I will say uh how many like how many like kids specifically
right now just
thank you very much for the raid. Welcome welcome like without
us like instantly just changing it. Like why does the UN not
care enough? Like what the you know like I like that's the thing
basically always worked against the interests of Israel. I thought
that was the case. Is that not the case?
UN quite literally established Israel. Uh uh England essentially
forced to put the UN did not establish Israel. Hold on. Yeah.
You UN established Israel. Yeah. Zionism project. I'm pretty
sure Israel Israel uh established Israel. Literally the UN was
like, "Okay, this seems like a fair partition." Wait, no, no,
no. Hold on, hold on. The Israelites, okay, not the Israelites.
Why did I say that? The Israelis. Okay, the proto-Israelis, the
Jews in historic Palestine, in the mandated, British mandate
of Palestine submitted a partition plan that they thought seemed
reasonable. And the Arabs said, "Fuck you." And so the UN went,
"I guess this could be a partition plan." And then the went,
we're now Israel with that partition plan. And the Arabs were
like, "Actually, you we're going to kill you now." Is that not
how it went? I could have sworn this is how it went down. So
this is how I understand it of going down. So and like I can
get into this. So in World War II, like before World War II ended,
Christian Zionists and uh Scandinavia and Europe, I think, or
just Scandinavia, North Northern Europe, probably whatever like
that entire all those islands, probably some of Poland and something,
you know, like whatever. Uh point is Poland was worried about
Israel and Okay. Yeah. There was there was a bunch of Christian
Zionists that wanted to essentially solve the Jew problem again,
you know, freaking every time. This was pre World War II or in
World War II. PreWorld War II, they wanted to do this before
World War II. Like this stuff was discussed before that, but
then after after World War II was actually enacted, right? Because
there was a genocide against so like, you know, it's there was
justification, safety for, right? So Zionist, we got we got a
name on any of the Christian Zionists.
Uh, not on off the top of my head. Sorry. Do we have any names
of the movements or anything I can Google to look up this story?
You should be able to look up Christian Zionists of the 1930s
to 1950s that started the talks of establishing Israel on historic
or not historic Palestine potentially. I don't know if they had
that plan at that point, but just establishing Israel a state.
So this is like really significantly after the first aliyah.
Is that even after the second aliyah?
Uh I'm not sure but I will say this there was there was so the
only people so the UN definitely supported it. It was essentially
a global communion thing right because the UN kind of started
at the same time as this right. So the UN was establishing Israel
as a state. So like you know a state could exist never establish
Israel as a state. What do you mean it's literally in the UN?
Yes. The UN did not establish Israel as a state. Israel established
the Jews as a state. Palestine said we are Israel. These are
our borders. Fight me. When I No, that is that is kind of wrong
actually. Um it's the UN said that Palestine should be split
into a Israeli uh a Jewish and Arab state. They said that and
then they had people submit their partition plans for it. For
example, Palestine wasn't uh until recently was not put into
uh the UN as well, like established in UN as a state as well.
Okay. Like because of Islamophobia, dude. Like oh my gosh. It
go they literally didn't they didn't submit border like a border
partition plan and they didn't even declare a country. They just
Okay, I kind of got mogged to be honest, but sorry. They had
they had an Arab coalition. They didn't really give a about them
and just moved in, right? looking to swallow up all that land.
So England owned in their eyes owned Palestinian land uh unbeknownst
to the Palestinians, right? The Palestinians are like, "No, that's
our land." And also the Ottoman Empire there. Do you know the
Ottoman Empire? And do you know the first in Yeah, obviously.
Infid
in. There you go. I'm really bad at pronouncing sometimes. Um
no worries. Uh but the first one was actually the breaking up
of the Ottoman Empire or at least the new colonial one. Um uh
so essentially Turkey was the main you know install and stuff
right and then uh and then everybody else kind of just became
their own nation states and Palestine had their own uh own uh
thing as well. Then uh the then this happened right after World
War II the uh uh the population global population was essentially
encouraged to go to Israel and because of that it was further
justified to forcibly or as close to forcibly or pressure Israelis
to leave. like there's definitely um anti-semitic hate that happens
because obviously every nation has those unfortunately
um and we're not that great at preventing it uh although I will
say the internet community does a okay job and then after that
they essentially England said they could go here back to Israel
back to the homeland you all love Jerusalem right uh and this
was before Jerusalem was global land by the UN because the UN
wasn't a thing um Uh, and then they Can I ask you Can I just
ask you what purpose you have in dumping this information? I'm
just I'm legitimately just a little bit curious. You're saying
we're just trying to figure out I'm just I'm asking you because
what you're trying to argue right now is the UN established Israel,
right? Yeah. I'm about to tell you the part that you're saying,
but why? I had to tell you that other part because UN was a part
of that. UN essentially established that Israel can be a state,
right? Wait, did the UN have any jurisdiction over Israel? Like
before the British basically said, "We don't want control of
this anymore. We're giving up giving it up to the UN." The UN
didn't exist before World War II, did it? Yeah. Exactly. The
UN was formed after World War II. So the the British controlled
it completely. And it's a census of agreement between the world.
That's what the UN really is, right? Is that really it wasn't
international law yet. It was a census. That's how most of the
international or the programs themselves are made. So it was
a census between the world. Like for example, the Catholic the
Catholic Church was anti-Semitic at the time and radical Catholics
love this by the way because they love the old freaking Catholic
freaking frustrating Um potentially not awful to Islamic people.
Yeah, thank you. Isn't that interesting?
I I just always say they killed our Lord. Of course they were.
But I go ahead. Uh but yeah, the uh uh uh that Catholic said
Israel shouldn't exist. Like it was a global discussion. It wasn't
just, you know, one person's decision, only people's decision.
It was a whole global project
um uh after World War II especially. Uh and then yeah, people
did go in there and guess what they did? They went to people's
homes and just took them and said, "Leave or die." Some died.
Wait, when when was this? Hold on. When was this? This was the
invasion of Palestine. This was when they were settling in Palestine.
That is how years. O I don't know. I 1946 probably, right? Like
it probably Okay, you're talking you're talking about like the
planned out uh planned out and the knockb essentially is what?
Yeah, I'm talking about the fir the the first time it happened
and then yeah, you understand that like there was between what
do you hold on I don't even know off the top of my head, but
what did Israel's population go to from like
1940 to 1947? Like you're saying this is when they invaded, but
like I think they had already basically built up a lot of their
infrastructure there already, but I don't know. Maybe there was
a massive swell. I actually don't know. Actually, maybe it is
before No, it it's definitely not before World War II. World
War It was after World War II ended. That was 1945, right? I
don't know. I'm tired. What the 1945? I'm just trying to see
it happened about a year after World War II. So 46, 47. Yeah.
Was the first time that went in there then. had already established
a major population center there, right? Oh, well, no. Yeah, people
were in Palestine. Yeah, of course. So, yeah,
they had concerted efforts over time to send there to to start
their pilgrimage to there like they Zionism was well underway
at that point. I thought potentially, but I don't I don't think
it it definitely wasn't like a global discussion like with like
common people especially at that time. Um, I would say it's probably
more of just people in the founder of Zionism 40 years before
World War II ended, right? The founder. Yeah. Okay, that makes
sense. Yeah. See, like I didn't know that far about far gone.
I just knew uh right before uh World War I. Zionism was a thing.
See, Zionism was a thing. They were pushing people. They were
pushing people to immigrate to Israel for quite a while. Okay.
I mean, yeah. I mean, that makes sense. But it like you call
it Israel, but it was Palestine at the time. So, yeah. I I suppose
that does make sense. That's I That kind of sounds like a conspiracy
honestly, but I mean that's definitely a Zionist Christian project.
Christian nationalism does do like that sometimes.
What where's the Christian part? Where are the Christian Zionist
stuff coming from? Where's that coming from? Where are you adding
this? So Christian, I've seen a decent amount of the history
of this region. I have no idea what you're talking about. That
is very Christian Zionist, Christian Zionists have the idea of
that uh Israel specifically like in US they're Christian nationalists
and Christian Zionists typically um but uh in in Israel if the
if uh all of Israel is taken over like taken over by the Jewish
population so it becomes a complete state that will be the second
coming right like you know revelations kind of even though that
was clearly a metaphor for Rome and it already happened and clearly
showed that Jesus's teachings were based as So, I don't know
why they freaking take it farther and go like, "Oh, let's just
more brown people freaking Africans." Sorry. But yeah. So, do
you think like Christian Zionists are basically enacting some
kind of like retribution for essentially losing out in the Crusades?
Uh, no. I don't know. Like they were trying to take over the
world with Crusades. I mean, they just they're just trying to
get their, you know, in their eyes, they're trying to they think
the world is about competition, right? And God made it that way.
So therefore, the strong will win and the fruits of our labor
show all. So like we have a bunch of money, therefore we are
justified in all essentially is is kind of what they go with.
Like we're justified in all for our own furtherment of power
and luxury I guess. I mean I don't know some might not care about
luxury but all of them care about power that much I know. Okay.
Yeah. I never heard about Christian Zionists being like foundational
in the or sorry uh like a tremendous force in the founding of
Israel. The song talks about it like they're definitely really
foundational because uh I mean like it's how do I say really?
I mean to some people it might not be really because it's it's
not as like public as you're saying, right? Like the like England
is what most people know, right? like and and pal and like you
said it people in general, right? Um, but it definitely is more
of like the insidious part of it. Like the the roots behind it
essentially like that it was essentially about disrupting the
reason it got popular. Like when you're quiet, right, to the
public, but you're still acting on or enacting and uh doing activism,
I suppose, as a Zionist. Like that means you're going behind
the scenes spreading the word, right? Meaning it's spreading
the word. like even if it doesn't get seen often, people are
people. They have memory as well, right? Um and that kind of
encouraged this plan of enacting a colony in the Middle East,
which has been this center of global
wait. Just I just need to go through the last couple things you
just said. So, you said um when you move quietly behind the scenes,
people aren't stupid. They have memories. Um, yeah. And that
led to the founding of a colony in the Middle East.
Well, it's well, it encouraged that dialogue, right? Like before
it's essentially, it might not even be intentional, right? Like
they might not have cared about being popular or not. It was
like that time period where it wasn't the internet, right? So
being popular wasn't as dangerous. Um but I would say um they
most likely you know were focused on spreading the word to very
specific people that could you know had actual power to change
things like it kind of usually more dangerous stuff as well.
Uh but you know for Christian Christian well because those people
are people who are serious about what they're doing and that
world was definitely violent. I mean, it still is as we're talking
about, right? Uh the Middle East,
every everywhere. Everywhere. Here in the US, it definitely is.
Have you ever talked to the police? Some police aren't exactly
friendly. Some are. Uh I'm very white, so my my conversations
with the police are always friendly. Okay. Yeah. Be a little
antagonistic and see how friendly they actually are. Some the
ones that make fun of you, don't be antagonistic with because
they don't give a about you. Trust me. I just thought I was nice
to them and then they're nice back to me. It's like it's like
uh I'm like a Jedi. I'm like, "Hey, how was your day?" And they're
like, "Oh, it's good. How was your day?" And I'm like, "Oh, mine
mine's also good. Was I speeding?" They're like, "No, no, you
know what? Actually, you should go. It's good time." Yeah. This
is not the white leftist you're looking for. Okay. I mean, yeah.
I mean, I just definitely I definitely always be real kind of
thing. And often when I'm real with the police, like I I told
them straight up like the first few times I talked to him like
I don't like y'all. It's kind of funny.
What were you talking to them for when you got first time you
got real deal with the police?
Uh no. Okay, that was not real. Hate the MPD. Um maybe not hate,
but
um what was the first time? I don't I don't know. Like I got
a ticket the first time honestly. But if I'm talking about that
time that I take it for speeding. Um but the uh I hate speeding
tickets. Yeah, it was a while ago. Um the uh what's it called?
Um yeah, that was freaking frustrating. Um beyond belief. Uh
but the uh the thing that I called them or talked to him about
was actually harassment and uh and stuff by well Christian nationalist
actually and uh rape as well. But the first time I talked to
him, the was who got someone that I didn't necessarily know but
looked like a coworker. Very long story, man. It's And as well
as another person that also probably was the coworker. I think
it was but and then others. The coworker and the doppelganger
were in trouble. And the doppelganger.
Well, it looked like Sorry, I just used the word. Yeah, I know.
That's that's kind of interesting though. It It definitely looked
like that in that sense. it like really only body type as well.
Body type and hair. Very frustrating. Oh, and nationality of
course cuz you know they're racist. Where do you live? Minnesota
cops. A Christian nationalist. I mean I don't know. Probably
there there's a probably a cop that helped them but I just don't
know. Dude, it's harder with cops because they're people who
are way more serious, right? You don't with cops kind of thing,
right? Like no. Like if you're remember when I said if you're
gonna do something serious and bad, you gotta do it for a good
reason. You gotta be smart about it, right? Like that goes like
Yeah, I didn't I learned that lesson the hard way. They're kind
of dumb though as well. It's frustrating. It's It's really frustrating.
But they definitely don't give a They don't say much at first.
They always say really really creepy. So the cops are the Christian
Zionists.
Christian Zionist. Cops also don't say much, but they usually
ask questions. Oh, Christians. Zionists in general. Yeah. Or
Christian Zionist and Christian nationalists are definitely not
monolith. of your group has uh varants like definitely right
like dude okay you know do you know Sam Harris at all not personally
but you've heard of him right the atheist yep yeah meditation
guy yeah yeah I he's a freaking Islamophobic now granted this
is kind of interesting what do you think of the Taliban the first
thing that I ask you first thing I think of the Taliban uh Osama
bin Laden okay interesting how about just right now modern times
um Pakistan mountain goats Okay, Pakistan mountain goats. That's
fair. Pakistan part is hard to justify this. But the point is
Taliban is not all he says specifically Taliban has no moral
value. To me that is unbelievably Islamophobic as because Taliban
is obviously a lot of people and they obviously have a lot of
different perspectives still and yes they're mainly a fundamentalist
uh religious state but or governance but they're still they have
any values that overlap with you uh I mean they have values that
overlap all of us for example you value the sanctity and protection
of family for example and private Y absolutely. But hold on.
They probably actually think that um I you could say that, but
I'm sure they would believe in things that like would essentially
come down to an eye for an eye. You don't believe in that, right?
Like if somebody killed your like sister, you wouldn't kill their
sister in retribution, right? False. I disagree with if that
was if that was the case, Taliban would be considered an active
terrorist group currently. And it's not like it doesn't it doesn't
uh it doesn't incite uh terrorist action elsewhere besides I
suppose. Are you arguing that that the tribes that would make
up the Taliban would not get into blood feuds and debts over
like uh like dishonors done to their family? I this was basically
the the culture that the Taliban had formed in with this sort
of um oh what would you call it?
Like it was basically like waring clans. Like that's what a lot
of the um the less habitable Middle East is is a lot of waring
factions. I just think it's more complicated than that. Like
yeah, they could, but definitely not all and there would definitely
be resistance. It's just it's a matter of details, you know?
Like the point is is that there is moral value in them. Saying
statements such as they have no moral value, like that's extremely
dangerous. That's a lot of people that he just said have no reason
to be alive. I would want you to if you want to say that they
have moral value, I would ask you to to name the the facet of
their culture or moral system that is better than ours.
Liberation from imperialism. Okay. Is that how they see it? Liberation
from imperialism. I mean, that's what it is. But yeah, that's
how they see it. It's how Iran sees it as well. That's why there's
so many stories about how Iran's teaching kids to hate uh US
uh US people. But if you ever have talked to anyone from Iran
that grew up as a kid during that during those topics, they have
never said so. So I like maybe Iran governance says to do it
and then the teachers just go like why? Like we got you know
math and reading to focus on. Okay. Hold on a second. Sorry.
Sorry. Okay. Okay. So from there you basically believe like Sorry.
Sorry. Sorry. Frenzy fries. I do not agree with that. I 100%
disagree with that. That is awful. Like I did definitely do not
agree with majority of what Taliban does. But the point is there's
a lot of people including women. All right. Just connected to
that. And you need to understand that like essentially vilifying
them is close to what Zack Raw or Asmin Gold got banned for.
All right. And he's still doing it as well. Yeah. I uh I unfortunately
basically I I thought you know you don't get to kill people for
this but I I broadly agree that the culture is basically a lesser
culture in nearly every way. I don't think they have very much
to teach us. I do think this is just a lesser culture. Yes. What
do you think culture is? Like how would you describe it and I
will clarify mine. Mine is different than the scholar of the
broadly like um I don't know what what would you call it like
the prevailing moral opinions of a group of people would be their
their culture you could say like culture in terms of music is
I'm not really talking about music I'm talking about like philosophical
culture how you treat people how you treat um minorities how
you treat you know what gender relations are like values and
traditions yeah sure values and traditions let's say values and
traditions okay I don't think I don't think those people are
like morally reprehensible and I don't think there's anything
like any genetic component I think take somebody from that culture
at a young age and implant them in whatever other culture and
they'd be fine. I don't think there's like anything inherent
there. But I do think people who grow up in that culture will
as adults have views that I would never want represented significantly
in a country I lived in. Okay. Sure. I just have a problem with
saying like I definitely disagree with a lot of the uh traditions
that are still upheld. Um like in Iran for example, woman got
killed for taking off her hijab. I believe in choice. Uh there
are plenty of women though that also want to wear hijab. So I
believe in choice. So I don't believe in saying oh hijab is oppressive
as well, right? That's just not the case. Like they even they
even style the hijabs. It's just like clothing, right? Obviously
because it is clothing obviously. Uh anyway, but the the idea
that I would go with instead of saying that they are inferior
because they're not inferior.
trying to say that they're inferior is like how how do you quantify
or even like assess that like put one over the other. We're the
imperialist nation that is quite literally the reason why the
Taliban came into power again, you know, like they could have
been going towards progress kind of like how Iran was. But yeah,
there was definitely suppression by oh surprise surprise the
authoritarian government again like you know everywhere else
including here. Um but uh but yeah, it's you just the uh the
whole point is that they that who's worse the people who force
that situation essentially are killing these individuals and
forcing uh oppression onto them uh because
uh for their own power uh which then justifies these autocracies
like the Taliban to come into power and then take over. It's
like almost their plan. In fact, it keeps the whole center of
the world, center of globalization completely disrupted the whole
time so that these other powers who shouldn't have complete control
of the whole world can continue to have control of the whole
world. Like look at the countries that are on the US's side like
the UAE, Saudi Arabia. Their technological advancements alone
should tell us enough that quite literally they are able to grow
as a a as a society faster than we are. So who's less than, who's
more than, it's clearly more complicated. UAE is considered an
authoritarian government as well and it has very similar traditions.
Okay. Do you think um I So I kind of understand what you're saying.
So would you would you blame that on America chiefly or would
you blame that on Israel chiefly? US. Okay. I'm sure you've heard
that the like the What do you think about US and Russia? Russia
Russia Russia's invasion of of uh of Afghanistan was the beginning
of dismantling
uh the Taliban
um and which radicalized them further into autocracy.
Oh. So, you think um you think it was bad for them to resist
uh like communism and socialist like socialist communist rule?
No, I think it was good. And also, it wasn't communist, it's
fascism. I don't know why I said wrong. Yeah, you were saying
good. Sorry, I I mischaracterized you. I meant to say um you
think it was good for them to do that. Okay. To to resist. Yeah.
I mean, resist us, resist them, resist anybody that doesn't belong
on, you know, you don't let someone just take over your house,
right? It's the same thing there. Like, that's your family. That's
your that's your people and they they're literally trying to
make your family go into harm's way at best or quite literally
put them in harm's way or do harm on them at worst. Like that's
you got to defend at that point. It's frustrating as heck. I
wish there was a way to just make everyone stop being violent
at one point, right? Like I can just snap my fingers or something,
but even if I had the tech for that, man, just wouldn't work
that way. Brains are too powerful. Um, okay. Okay, hold on. Hold
on. I got to I now I'm trying to think. Sorry, I was going down
the um Have you not heard the argument that like Israel has influenced
the US into most of their operations since like the 1970s, 1980s
in the Middle East? Like under the guise of like have you not
heard like a lot of these theories that the US has like influenced
or sorry the Israel's influenced the US into most of their military
operations since like the 1970s, 1980s. That doesn't even make
any sense. We we quite literally trained the Israelis. It's a
It's a freaking relationship, not a oh, one has control over
the other. They're two different powers. Like, think about it.
They're real people, right? There's a reason that Biden said
Apac has like Do you think Apac has like no influence at all?
What? No, they had definitely have influence, but not like direct
influence is the whole point. It's not a freaking conspiracy.
I ain't no freaking anti-semitic conspiracy theorist, dude. Oh,
you saw me type in chat. You're full of you. God damn it. Oh,
I up. I did not see you type in chat actually, but whatever.
It's It's okay. A dude that uh that I Yo, this actually might
be interesting. What's the uh Did he leave? Okay. What was the
guy? There's a dude called that has a show called The Revenant
who's a radical Catholic.
Okay. And he essentially
um is what you're saying with that, right? like he thinks Israel
controls like a lot of um uh the US operations and he also think
it thinks Israel controls like not controls but influences greatly.
Like that's the thing. They're not necessarily dumb about it
either, right? There's a reason he has a million freaking subscribers
and a ton of views and still not banned, you know? Like he he
knows how to freaking walk on that line, too. Like I don't know.
Catholics, I think, actually have always walked on that freaking
line. And I I grew up Catholic. And I will say a lot of a lot
of them did. And I definitely definitely have. It's it's kind
of scary because I like is he good? Is he bad sometimes? Definitely
bad. But like, you know, how bad? Like does he is he the one
like facilitating any violence or is he just being there? Like
what is he doing kind of thing, you know? Okay, I got it. Okay,
final question. Um well, final set of questions. What do you
think about the diplomat shooting shot? the two diplomats set
free Palestine, two Israeli diplomats. Yeah, I disagree with
that. They're non-combatants and it doesn't help anything. Unless
if those diplomats were going to enact a law that would have
killed a lot of people. Then I wouldn't justify it, but I would
essentially say, what do we do to self-defend against that? It's
like, well, you have to go through the democratic process. What
if it's gatekept from us, therefore causing violence on us because
we don't have any way to stop the violence that they're about
to pass legally? So based on that, you 100% think Luigi is justified,
right? I definitely should not be killed for it. Sure. Okay.
No death penalty. Justified. Once again, I wouldn't say that.
I would essentially say, well, that's the thing. I definitely
kind of disagree with his stance, but you know, like for example,
like the only thing I've seen it even help with besides just
get a bunch of attention and people horn dogging after him, honestly,
which is hilarious, but whatever. also not in a sense um is like
there's one state was it Virginia potentially
um that passed a law called the Luigi Manoli Act where you can
sue in civil cases against these insurance companies but I I
just want to like point out how ridiculously ineffective that
is. I want you to imagine being an insurance company with insurance
being sued by someone for making more money. What do you think
your strategy for that would be? Oh, probably just to abuse the
system more to, you know, uh, cut that deficit. Like very frustrating.
Um, but yeah. Yeah. Okay. All right. All right. I think, uh,
that's probably it. I think my my stream has ended or it's about
to end. So, thank you very much for coming on. I enjoyed the
talk. Yeah. Thanks, man. I appreciate it. It was actually it
was it was good. I talked a lot, but you had always had good
questions, honestly, and good points. Nice. Nice. That's awesome.
Yeah, thank you for coming on. Uh, feel free to call in again.
I